all right and we are live
the last word with no incognito and
ivantas fresh on that friday evening
care fire how we do
how we doing sir nice little guest today
what's going on man yeah we got an
awesome guest we'll get them in here in
a second uh just a little housekeeping
things to start off with
um for all you guys that have been
listening to our episodes on youtube
both on iron lords podcast and my you
and the abanti's youtube channel
thank you guys but i also want to let
you guys know for the audio platforms we
are out there itunes spotify and more so
if you guys want to look us up uh it's
just the last word with ibontis and
lordcognito
we've been growing on audio so i wanted
to thank all of you guys who do listen
out there so thank you guys very much
keep it going share it with your friends
and if you're on one of those platforms
we can you know follow us or drop a
review
always helps please do yes very much
appreciate it
but that being said it's an exciting
time in gaming as scions tried to start
some stuff in destiny
we will be we'll be landing in enoch in
less than a week
as our fresh off the boat outriders we
will once again gather on the campfire
to talk about these games we enjoy but
first
it's time to celebrate our special guest
this week we are joined by a man who
started on gaming so young he used them
to learn to read
his origins are with pokemon elder
scrolls and halo
so when destiny went live many years ago
it was a must play
with his background in graphic design
and stand up comedy streaming and
content creation was an
easy step after he found the right
community his work in it means his setup
will always be locked in and ready to go
but it's his passion to help others
where he really is doing something
special
you can see that on his twitch streams
while he carries many guardians through
gm's in a cool and collected manner
his kindness doesn't stop in gaming as
he also works in real life doing mental
sherping
for all those men and women in uniform
many people have this man
to thank for many reasons and we are
very lucky to have him join us tonight
so without further ado let's welcome the
owner of the anti-sherpa
sherpa club writer and pve guide
specialist for tracker network
host of the before you respawn podcast
managing partners of the advanced.gigi
brand hailing from pittsburgh
pennsylvania
and recently engaged to a very lucky
lady
the one and only how are you doing this
evening sir well this is your life baby
bad dude i need that i need a recording
of that wow
that is a list that's your best friend
that was the best one yet yeah
that was great i'm high high ranking
high ranking super high ranking
i was like i'm out of breath listening
to
all of that i was like man i you you
were just like saying things
like yeah i guess i do do that don't
that i was just like
i was like man yeah it's like we're
doing this information
google does wonders but that's cool yeah
google is
yeah no google's amazing yeah you
learned so much on google
yeah yeah wow yeah yeah right exactly
exactly listen cognito your turn let's
jump in i started it so now you're up
yeah yeah man first of all tremendous
i'm like running away by the nature i
was amazing
um yeah man look man tremendous to
finally have you up
at the campfire talking to talk but we
gotta talk a little a little history a
little gaming man little game
got a unique background i saw a game in
particularly
that caught my eye which is the elder
scrolls series so
talk to me about that influence because
when you share that i want to know where
you where you're at with elder scrolls
why that means to you
man dude elder scrolls is like the game
you know like
that is uh man i don't know i don't know
what it is about me and elder scrolls
like clix
um because like right off the bat i'm
just going to put the put out there i
don't like world of warcraft at all
like not even a little bit so that's
like that's like my elder scrolls though
so it's like
i can see yeah because i've never played
elder scrolls
so okay okay that's crazy yeah yeah
wait see i've at least played wow okay
i've i've played
i'm sorry no i never do yeah no no
not not even um but yeah so elder
scrolls
um original xbox elder scrolls morrowind
is what got me into the franchise
yeah it has like top tier
my absolute favorite um elder scrolls
game to dates uh the customization was
limitless you could do so many things
yeah you could make a levitation spell
that just lasted the entire time
like of your gameplay it was yes there
was so much
stuff that you could do it's so good in
the the sneak mechanics and the level up
mechanics
it's like dnd but in an entire game
without losing any of the magic of dnd
yes and as a series it's like the
seasons
the the season the series has like
gotten more popular over the years and
so like they've moved down to oblivion
and now to i mean
ever if i say skyrim you think of like
90 different versions of it
um to where it's more simple uh
simplified now to where like
but man elder scrolls uh morrowind just
has that charm
and that like beauty to it to where it's
so complex
yeah like like a bontes like if you hit
something
in elder scrolls morrowind it's a dice
roll like you don't know how much damage
you're going to do it's
random every time it's a it's a rolled
dice basically it's so
so good but yeah so elder scrolls is
like
that's that's rpg to me so quick
question so
morrowind is number one i get it yep the
complexity you're first
i understand launched with d-o-g x-box
right on time
so my question i gotta ask what's number
two
i'm gonna draw you with a curveball with
this one oh here we go
number two mm-hmm elder scrolls online
they somehow did such a good job at
making it into an mmo
um and i love the lore of elder scrolls
and the fact
elder scrolls online takes place 500
years before the actual elder scrolls
game
most of the elder scroll game timelines
so you get you get to
like for example in their moral one
expansion you actually get to see more
one being built and stuff like that like
yes it's so good they did such a good
job and
i like playing with people i like
playing with friends so the fact that i
can take
you know that that elder scroll love and
share with other people have a clan have
a guild
it's just it's perfect yeah that's a
good one
yeah good point man they've come such a
long way and um i remember when it first
started i still liked it when it first
started and then to see where it's
advanced to now and then the expansion
they literally bringing in all the other
universes
yeah awesome choice that's what i got e
i touch every now and then yeah so you
go farther back and you got it sitting
behind you over that left shoulder the
pokeball
cause that's like what started the game
it's
so good this is the uh uh if you guys
did i cast the one i heard this is a
diecast one
i had to do it i had to do it um i love
i love it it changes color like look at
that it's so crazy
just uh just okay it changes colors i
swear to change colors there you go
so you can like say like what kind of
pokemon you have in there you know with
the color that goes
like i said back to purple that's the
thing um it's crazy it's super heavy
super super heavy uh i got it i wasn't
planning on getting it but then um
jojo uh i posted a video of hers and i
was
i was over the moon about it i was like
okay fine i'll get it whatever i have to
god do it i was like i can't not have it
so you started with pokemon like the ogs
like the red and blue
yeah yeah yeah so um uh i am
i am 24 years old um i was 23 up until
like a week ago
um but my fiance corrected me she's like
you know you're 24 right man
you're 23. i was like am i really 24 and
she's like yeah you're 24.
i was like okay great sweet thanks for
making me old
uh
[Laughter]
yes man
but uh but yeah so so pokemon started it
all um
i grew up uh i'm very fortunate i have
an
amazing aunt who was very close in age
to me whenever
we're growing up and so she had a game
boy um
growing up and it was like the the big
you know the big platform game boy
um and uh so that was pokemon red those
pokemon red on that
and uh like i would just sit there and
like try to sound out the words and
stuff like that like i knew pokey center
i was like three or four years old
whenever i learned and how to do this
and so i would like walk up to the signs
read the signs on the on the front of
the buildings
and just sound out the words that's so
cool like
so do you have like i know it's probably
almost impossible do you have like a top
three pokemon
oh man all right i mean is purple one of
them behind you is that like ghosts or
anything like kangaroo or anything
like ghosts ghosts and psychic pokemon
are definitely like my top
favorites my all-time favorite pokemon
is actually sitting next to the pokeball
um his name is his name is ditto oh
so yeah yeah i'm one i'm one of those
like those ditto stands like i love it
i love ditto um
number one but it also battles with the
uh that new meltdown pokemon i don't
know
how familiar you guys are with pokemon
go but it like got thrown in there
it's it's just a metal looking ditto but
it's it's better
you know it's a steel type um so i
i love love uh love meltan and then my
man you of course you did top three too
so it's like oh yeah
like so here's here's the third i'm
gonna put down a list of thirds
so it's either onyx uh corvie knight
from the sword and shield games we got
driftloon in there
we got luxury we got there's so many
pokemon i don't know i can't
the third one ditto and miltan gets
spots one and two
but it's still a tie everything after
that i don't know
yeah that's just been impressive yeah
just to see
the the tremendous like how much turnout
in the fan base of
i still never really played one yeah you
know like to see
how impressed how large expansive it is
is it's crazy
oh yeah it's insane it's it's absolutely
the same i mean you see switch just blow
up
even when one of those was announced
absolutely crazy
yeah absolutely what's going to ask you
is um we've had a lot of guests on and
normally
you know for most people not all but um
the transition before destiny usually is
halo
into into dusty surprisingly a lot of
people who have not either played halo
but you're not one of them
you are part of the normally
transitioning bungie people
into destiny so it's cool so tell me
about like the halo experience like
how was that for you when when did that
uh kind of get into your game in
repertoire
yeah so literally right when halo
launched um you know like i said i had
uh
um an aunt who's like same exact age i
had a cousin
same same kind of age as well um and so
it was
halo just it was there you know so we
started playing halo um
that's obviously the i uh you know
shooting shooting things shooting aliens
is cool um i've never been a call of
duty fan for some reason like i like
modern warfare
two and three i think i was i was into
i've never liked like the black op
black ops games um and so like i don't
know like halo just like clicks
and you know bungie knows what they're
doing uh with this stuff like that and
so like it just worked
um halo 2 was cool halo 3 is like
obviously like
where you know it kind of blew up uh but
halo reach
my favorite game favorite halo game nice
halo race is nice
yeah that's nice h is real nice yeah
and uh i'm kind of glad that's a game
that bungie went out on you know yeah
like
no you know thankfully they're not
responsible for halo 4
or halo 5.
i either really just turned the audience
i just feel like they inherited someone
else's child
yeah yeah which is like which five i
heard has it war zone was it like the
pvp
thing that one was at least in cool and
concept that i heard was some people i
kind of enjoyed but like
from what you've said especially cognito
like the story on five didn't live up
and
like the the trailers i remember seeing
back and forth and that didn't pan out
so no i'm very curious when infinite
falls if they do
just kind of like a little etch-a-sketch
shake and just be like all right forget
the last stuff let's do something right
and see how they do it right now
look i'm gonna play it i'm not gonna lie
like i'm still gonna play it i'm
gonna try to you know try to enjoy it
i'm gonna look for
it you know it's just halo is a part of
my blood like it's just you know it's
like if a new pokemon game comes out now
like now i'm gonna play it like now i'm
now i'm at the spot like it doesn't
matter so are you excited about the idea
of a switch pro
i don't know i don't use my switch
enough i
really don't okay i do uh animal
crossing so my
my fiancee uh is not a gamer um
she whenever we met the most that she's
like really like
honed in on is sims which is you know
great game
um yeah but with the switch came animal
crossing
and i think i introduced you to animal
crossing yes
that's like a gateway drug for games and
we almost didn't get engaged because i
almost lost her
uh to playing animal crossing like she
every day wake up she would because like
it was at the beginning of the pandemic
when that game came out so she'd wake up
change her uh you know change her
character's outfit do
all the stuff i like walk by like you're
still like you've never heard of animal
crossing and so we had to buy her her
own switch
because i want to play animal crossing
because i've always loved animal
crossing
um which is weird for like the game
history that i play it's like yeah i
really can't wait to go shoot aliens and
it's like well after i attend my garden
before the storm right exactly yeah yeah
so
so we had to buy her her own switch she
now has so she got the animal crossing
edition switch like she's all about it
um and so i forget where i was going was
this oh yeah switch pro
uh so like the switch pro is i don't
know like i just don't use enough i use
enough uh i've i've tapered out on
animal crossing like i feel like most
people have by now
um and i really just used to play
pokemon
that's it like i'm not a i'm not a big
nintendo fan oh yeah it's surprising
though because you're such
it's like it feels like it feels like
yeah you're like this very
diverse yeah and unique kind of set of
tastes with gaming yeah because
most people in the camps that you
actually like
are usually diametrically opposed but
most guys are like the pokemon guys like
they like
in that bag they don't really mess with
shooters and any dude bro stuff or
whatever you know
exactly yeah halo was like shooting
aliens big you know massive set piece
but you still over there getting your
animal crosses like you got this exact
palace
it's so wild because like i also have
two other hot takes that like drive
people crazy all the time because i hate
i hate mario i don't like any mario game
that exists
a little bit but that's okay mario 64 is
like i love mario 64.
okay i respect that that's a good one i
cannot play any other mario game i'm
just like it's the same stuff over and
over again
if you i would recommend now that 3d
world's on there
if you did if you missed that on wii u
3d world that's actually really good
i did 3d world super mario bowser fury
but if you missed it on wii u that's
probably that's just a really good game
it's just fun yeah so it's not the three
it's not the mario 3d like odyssey would
be the one that would be closest to 64.
but
i hate it odyssey i don't even know if
that's gonna work
damn and then and then breath of the
wild this is my other hot take
i'm a huge legend zelda fan i guess i do
like another nintendo pro okay there we
go we got one
breath of the wild worst legend zelda
game
now let me ask you is it because of the
is it because of the durability
it's it's because i just doesn't follow
like the same mechanics and the same
like go through a dungeon get this
weapon kind of mechanical
every zelda game okay it just didn't
feel like one of the
metroidvania style types yeah unlocked
stuff
it felt like i was playing vanilla
skyrim you know like
not vanilla isn't no mods but vanilla
like this was like the alpha
of skyrim like before like and that's it
i gotta i gotta get him i gotta get him
i can't let this i gotta get him you
know what here's the thing
because you're coming for me and that's
cool but that's all jokes brother you
don't play with
wait i'm saying like it's funny you say
this because me and
addict go at it about this right
and i am i immediately i'm not like this
huge i haven't played
every single zelda but i've played a lot
sure right so breath of the wild
for me right the reason why i get all
crazy and excited about it i was like oh
wow they're finally 3d it's open world
you see that building in different
distance i can go there and i can climb
it to the top okay oh yeah yeah but yeah
when i speak to him
as the he literally he's gonna love
let's read listening to this because he
literally says what you say and he goes
cog is not
it's a good decent game but it's not a
great great game
and he's saying amazing game yeah he
says the reason why is he always says
the
dungeons he's like i hate the dungeon
and for a lot of zombies
they say it's not there's dungeons are
not the hardcore
typical zelda style dungeon so i do
respect what you're saying because
he's actually said that same foot and
like i like i like a lot of the 3d games
too it's like
i will breath of the wild is an
incredible game it's beautiful it's
spectacular it's amazing it's just not a
good zelda game
so like everybody exactly of course and
you know but just nothing's ever going
to be like you know wind waker or
ocarina of time
are both pretty epic i didn't play
twilight princess i've always heard good
things i played a decent chunk of
skyward sword i thought
that was coming and i was like i could
like it wasn't bad
but ocarina of time and both one waker
were two that i was like i think i
hundred percent of those and that was
those were kind of special ones for me
for sure so
nice yeah for sure yeah and then in the
world of gaming
obviously after halo comes the big uh
you know
behemoth walking in the room destiny
shows up on your doorsteps
about seven and a half years ago and
hunter ever since is that right hunter
ever since
uh d1 alpha okay
hunter you know it's just i don't know
i've always been like in
you know this is kind of where like the
elder scrolls comes in it's like i've
always been like the the sneaky
you know sneaky roll around like stabbed
the shots
if you watch any of my grandmaster runs
where i'm not throwing um i'm usually
like sneaking into things jumping out of
it
as soon as possible i mean i've always
been yeah all
void the whole time yeah speaks to you
the invisibility on hunters and grand
masters seems to be
really important to have at least one of
those with you for those clutch like
res moments and things like that the few
times that i've gone through those it's
really helpful to have one in a pinch
like they are can't value them enough
like to have at least one of those to be
able to go invis and save
save the day for a second yeah i used to
be super elitist too with classes you
know how like everyone's always like you
know i hate
i hate you know titans or i hate i still
make titan jokes all the time thanks
um like it's just it's just easy so like
i mean there's that although i did make
a pretty good warlock joke today and i
forget it now though but
anyway i uh i as i've become more of a
sherpa
i've just learned that like all three
classes have their strengths all you
know all three classes are beneficial
i'll play all three i just prefer to be
on my hunter and things go a lot
smoother than i am
that's it i heard on devil's lair that
the titan
ursa furiosa was like a really good
strat so it was like
it's so good oh it was
the best yeah the best the best like wow
absolutely the best
it i i did runs without it it's just not
it's just not the same it's not the same
just having that wall up to just be like
all right
yeah we're good yeah i mean like the the
walker tank that shoots at you he can
literally just expand the shield and eat
the
the shot i remember my kanejo who was
he was in chat i pulled up a like
we were we were in that room with the
walker tank and he was like i wonder if
i can just take the shot
and i was like yeah i don't know and
he's like well let's find out he just
jumps in front of the shot
with his ursas and it just it ate it it
was amazing oh
yeah the loot it's gonna actually be all
that subject is that favorite what are
your favorite uh hunter exotics of all
time
oh man my favorite included
you want like a top three or is this
like just people let's do it
okay all right just listening all night
long
yeah just make me do top three lists yes
um that's that's today that's the
podcast
the new on the oculus exotic i'm a big
invis fan so like that one
number one like absolutely uh business
let's go
yeah it's so good it's like they were
like you get two smoke bombs i want to
say less
and then i i really went for it haven't
taken it off that much
uh uh number
two um it's gonna throw everyone like
everyone chat's about to be like what uh
bombardiers the one where you dodge away
and drops the bomb
yeah yeah i have i have a montage tucked
away where it's just me
getting kills and crucible with
bombardiers
and like i'm bad and so i usually run
away from situations
and so now you run away with a bomb yeah
now i just run away they were like run
away with a bomb at your feet and i was
like okay cool this off this works
um a call of duty parkinson's probably
love if i cannot remember the name of it
oh i remember that one yeah yeah yeah
yeah you'd like so annoying
you'd like to drop your name you'd kill
the people yeah you know what yeah i
remember that
yeah i can see that in my head um and
then the third one man what's the
what's another exotic i love to use i
guess the the
frosties are great i saw some women in
chaplain frosties i love frosties
um stompies are great obviously because
you know who doesn't like
zooming yeah um yeah i think uh
i think faux tracer is another really
good one that i like to use though
i think that would be like my top three
just because i like um it pairs really
well with some like weird loadouts i do
weird loadouts in pvp
i don't like playing with meta weapons
i'm in the same way yeah
meta crew tonight well you're the
anti-sharper sherpa
explain that by the way i want to know
now more because it's the anti-sherpa
sherpa and you're like i'm sorry did i
say that too many times
yeah anti-sherpa sherpa um how's your
guys's language field in the in the uh
we're past
the first 30 seconds you're golden yeah
you're good all right good cool cool
cool
all right cool so uh fair warning
everybody yeah fair
fair warning i'm about to say a swear
don't want your mother here
uh so we called the ass club uh the
anti-sherpa sherpa club
um it was a we called it webclam for the
longest time and you're gonna love this
uh lori cognito because we it was the
webclan because
before that it was a mechanical spider
clan which was way too much to say and
the mechanical spider because of
the dwarven spiders and elder scrolls oh
that's absolutely man that's a deep deep
cut right there yeah yeah
there you go so there you go um and it
became ass club
um anti-sherpa sherpa club uh because i
was trying to do like a solo prophecy
like a year ago
yeah and we were just like talking about
stuff
i forget like we were talking about
something and then one of my mods said
like
uh i was i was talking about sherpa
stuff and then they were like well yeah
like we're like the anti-sherpas
um and now i'll get into that and the
reason why we're the anti-sherpas is
because like raise your hands in chat if
you've been on like an lfg
oh talk about it talk about it yeah i've
got stay respectful if you've
you know you've been on love site or
you've been like a lfg discord roman
already put it in here go ahead yup
yup and it's like you know what know
what to do
you know like you can come run with me
know what to do
must have gala horn must have 95 clears
must be seven time conqueror at the
beginning of the season
it's like it's like man like
and then you join the team and then like
you know half the time they don't even
know what to do and it's like damn
himself mm-hmm
and i remember you know growing up
um i never really had like a lot of
people to play with i never really
you know i didn't really have i couldn't
afford like xbox live and stuff like
that growing up
so i didn't really have you know many
people to play with uh you go
you know you go into that and then so
like in destiny like i
i really only had like my college
buddies i played with in destiny i would
like to watch streams every now and then
uh watch like videos on reddit and stuff
like that but i didn't really like have
like a group of people to play with
until
i started streaming and so like i
always remember like going into lfgs and
like i was always like man it's like so
hard to do
anything in this game it's like i would
love destiny way more if i could just do
more activities
yeah and so like as i started to like
kind of like gain traction with the
stream and like
the clan started to grow up a little bit
it was like you know what like let's
just
take everything away from the clan that
we hit that we're doing right now
let's call it auntie sherpa sherpa club
and let's build the entire clan around
doing nothing but just helping people
get
you know get through the raid for the
first time you know get grand master
clears get through
you know strikes get like if you need
help with a uh like you know an
uh a public event like who cares what it
is
like call on the anti-sherpa sherpa club
we got your back we'll get you through
nice no positivity i mean no nothing but
possibilities
nothing but positivity and just get you
through you know
absolutely absolutely that's that's what
it's all about now i respect respect
because
i mean it's the culture right i mean we
we as hardcore destiny players you know
it's something you see a little bit too
much
and you know you jump in those lfgs and
again
sometimes what's kind of funny is like
content just came out they'd be like
right you know know what to do have this
amount of clears and all this other
stuff and it's like bro come on and
like you said i've seen some really
toxic ones to the point where
like one mess up or you know dudes are
yelling at you what the hell i'm like
bro it's like
like i'm a grown man oh man you was in
front of me you would not
have that energy right now you're
talking to me on this chat
so we're not gonna do it i've had to
check a couple of dudes
but i feel you but it's like and i love
that whole mentality you know i'm saying
that you guys are bringing like look
come on through
right you know we're gonna help you out
and it encourages people because again
destiny is a game
that unfortunately for some some of the
the better activities
there's no matchmaking so you you need
that so i felt that one brother i
definitely respect what you guys are
doing
less than uh seven percent of people
have completed grand master
yeah less than seven percent of of
guardians across the board
i've completed a grand master it's
insane yeah i was like
and then yeah we'll kind of come back to
that one a little later but it's like
there's
many hurdles to get there much less the
difficulty on top of like the leveling
and everything else so by the time
somebody finally gets ready and then
they don't have anybody to run it with
and then they go look and be like all
right have all this be ready be like and
it's just like damn
so it's yeah it's awesome that you guys
are just like if you if
you can walk in the door we'll get you
to the finish line like that's all you
gotta do is show up that's
awesome i love that yeah that's that's
literally it yeah we do
i mean and that's that is like the
feedback that i wish i could pass on the
bungies that like
drop the the contest mode cap it's like
capital
1325. totally fine but just let people
in the door like
yeah you know whenever deep snow [ __ ]
came out i remember we did sherpas for
people
back then the light level cap i think
was like 12.60 the raid was like 12
20 12 30 i want to say we still brought
people in at 1200 like all right
i think 12 16 was like the lowest person
that we got through at the time
it's like i just let's get people
through like just let people experience
it man yeah
it's like they already put the cap on
you but it's like if there's a point
where you could
that's what she said like make it third
make it the powerful cap make it 1300
you may get smoked when you walk in the
door but at least somebody could
try and be like yes okay at least i know
this is going to kick my butt i got to
put a little more effort in
we've talked about we'll get to leveling
here a little bit but right yeah that
would be nice just to give more options
honestly i think for
so many activities pvp pve gambit like
sherpas
streams all that stuff crossplay is
going to be amazing for this type of
stuff to just be like
here's the join code jump in i like i
cannot wait to
it's so much of the community splinter
and don't get me wrong we love cross
save was
you know added right but just that
feeling when they launch that thing and
we're all
able to rock no matter what platform
that's going to be transformative and
destiny for sure
yeah i was talking about this the other
day uh in chat i mean there's like
there's there's like a whole slew of
people that are in my chat that don't
play on pc i'm a pc
guy i came from ps4 um
but like it's just you know it's one of
those things where it's just like i feel
like most streamers that do what i do
and like most streamers in general are
on pc
i mean not not all of them but a lot of
them really are on pc
because like we're already we're already
running our rig to
all the obs stuff most of the time it's
like it just makes sense
um that's like half of the reason why i
moved over it's like why
capture card and deal with those issues
when i can just you know so that's what
pushed me
and so i feel like whenever cross play
opens up it's just going to open the
floodgates i'm so excited
it's yeah i i smile every time i think
about it it's not the best
absolute best i was like taking a very
very hard turn because i want to go back
to a little bit of your history before
we get
too far all right yeah for sure stand up
comedy
yeah i i was like believe me there was a
deep google search and i was like oh i
have to poke at this thread so
yeah explain like how much you got to do
how you fell into it
drop us your favorite like joke or bit
that you got
uh see what's in the arsenal here all of
my jokes are always super situational
uh super super dry humor um
and so i don't know i always like
deliver like those one-liners and
my fiance makes fun of me for this all
the time because like i'll make a joke
and she's
she's like are you joking or like are
like because you didn't laugh or smile
at all
and i'm like yeah i was 100 a joke like
what i just said it's supposed to be
completely funny
um which is why i don't do stand-up
comedy anymore um
so this joke
i make really dumb jokes i didn't really
do too much it was like a college thing
i just like
you know just do like small things in
college uh how long was the run how long
was that yeah
was hitting the comments yeah it was all
like the local places
um that would you know that would
tolerate me um
and it's so yeah so like sir caveman
he's in he's in chat
um every time we run the deep stone uh
deep stone [ __ ] raid
uh you know there's the three augments
there's uh operator
scanner and suppressor and every time
someone's like oh i got suppressor and i
was like suppressor i hardly know where
it's like like it's not
original it's not funny uh yeah it's
okay there's my other that is like so
shazzal just put it in my gold mine yeah
the shadows will just put
that is my that is like that's the joke
that needs to be on my tomb
right now okay and here it is here it is
so every time we've all been the target
right you know
target has a magical gold mine called
the the clearance
section yes yes and every time
you know sutlich in go into into target
and we go up to the clearance section
and we're rounding the corner i always
go oh no it's time to go see uncle
clarence
and she and she goes
please stop talking embarrassing me
yeah she she keeps me so in check and i
love it
it's like one of my top five top three
favorite qualities of my fiance
number one she keeps me in check um yeah
that is that is my favorite joke of all
time
i i i have said it for the entire time
her and i have been together i have not
stopped saying it
it is an everyday thing
yeah she just she whenever we're turning
the corner in the tech department
she always just lets out a big sigh
because she knows it's coming soon
it's hilarious yeah
yeah but feel free to use it break up
your marriages
i've had plenty of like eye rolls in my
marriage that i yeah
yeah that would just like be another day
as well it's just like
i don't think i can roll my eyes harder
for some of the stuff i've said as well
so no it's good
i like the dry humor jokes the dad joke
i'm not a dad but the dad jokes fall and
you're like yeah
yep those those definitely happen i'm
gonna be a great parent one day
you're ready you're practicing you're
getting getting them all ready to go so
you can embarrass them absolutely
yeah exactly exactly so red is best look
at that because again
it's not easy not easy man getting also
getting up there putting yourself out
there in front of a crowd and
you know what i'm saying spitting with
spit so still doing that
know that yeah very cool yeah what else
we got
uh last one um i don't know how much you
can talk about but just like the work
you did
for um just kind of like the
psychological ops and stuff like that
and the
speeches you give for like the people in
uniform like that was just a really cool
thing and i just kind of wanted as if
you could kind of
shed a little light on what you did
there it sounded like really really cool
yeah yeah so um i grew up like i said
like
super crazy crazy life growing up um so
i grew up uh
a huge batman fan um huge huge batman
fan
um and so the whole time i was growing
up i wanted to be a detective
ah that was like that was like that's
that's what i'm gonna be whenever i get
older is
is a detective um things say
wow am i in a different field
yeah if i'm doing things different now
and so that's actually that's what i
went to college for and stuff like that
um
i went to to college in in pittsburgh
pennsylvania
yeah that's how i got there um and
so while i was there i studied there the
program
uh that was made like in response to uh
the stuff that happened with 9 11. um
it was made it was a program by the
government it was called uh intelligence
and national security
uh so so that was my major um and so
that was my first joke of uh of my
stand-up routine was uh i majored in
intelligence um
because it's like the dumbest thing to
say uh you know
no offense to everyone else who's doing
great from the program but yeah
absolutely
my major is intelligence and it's like
okay all right wise guy
yeah right guy um so while i was in that
program
i did a whole bunch of like i had so
many cool opportunities
um and learned a lot the classes were
insane but
i will i will say that like the the
course work that they do
is is like the weirdest um not the
weirdest the
just like so different from like you
know
my friends who were like studying to be
like you know scientists or
like reporters and like they were like
oh yeah i have to write a paper today
and it's like oh well i have to learn
how many satellites russia has
up in the sky it's like it's the same
thing
it's just like you just know you're
you're on a different uh
different major and so yeah so one of
the things i did like while i was there
was i worked with the
uh there was a group of us who worked
with the us army uh
to do psychological training to like
learn how
like to teach them like how to talk to
people
overseas yeah yeah okay
to talk to people to be a good guy to
talk to people to get information
out of them um and so yeah it was it was
it was an interesting thing i mean it
was
interesting to say the least i guess is
the best way to put it and so yeah so i
did that
um and i've also i worked for a police
department for a long time
doing um security work and stuff like
that
uh yeah i mean it was great it was a
cool experience
um it's just it's one of those things
where it was like
i i'm a very like independent person
and a very independent thinker right and
i don't follow direction
very well is it an authoritative thing
just one of those things where it's like
i always feel like i know what the right
thing is
and i don't like doing the wrong thing
to do the right thing and so i just kind
of learned that that
my personality and that field doesn't
really mix well together yeah yeah
yeah that's tough because it's like
orders and you're like yeah they want
supreme structure and hierarchy and yeah
yeah
and so when it's one of those things
where it's like well i want to help
people in the world
but i necessarily can't be batman in
real life
and i don't want to listen to get the
steps to be a batman in life
right so this it's just one of those
things where it's like it's just not
going to work out it's not going to work
you know no no
no yeah that's where me and in the
detective part of ways i guess is the
best way to put it enough but that's
interesting yeah
a great great diversity there to see how
he's transformed from that that is his
job
left in albuquerque there that's for
sure so to fill in to be like okay so
so for for those people who are just
like okay it's cool so he decided he
didn't want to help the government so
he's a streamer now
it's like no there's a little there's a
little small little small sliver i'll
throw that in there so
i was like well i need a job that's not
this job i love technology
nice so i lived in an
area that had like a whole bunch of
apple stores around it um my buddy
uh needed to get this phone fixed we
went to an apple store talking
technology
they um told me to apply i got the job i
grew
in apple and then while i was there i
just learned that like i had like that
creative passion
you know and wanted to come out and so
here i am
that got me into streaming and gaming
and well back into streaming and gaming
and so now are you still apple are you
pc
cool yeah i have a pc
i have a pc um i don't like it i
to get the job done um all my videos um
i do all my
like i edit all my recordings and stuff
on uh on my macs
um i like i just i like apple a lot more
um after i left apple
um which i did recently um i i bought an
android phone i have an android phone
and it's gotta be tough for you
i hate it uh i would like to say guys do
not like it right
well i have a switch to android from the
iphone just because you like sound like
you like the apple ecosystem i'm curious
i love the apple ecosystem
like this right here like behind me like
that's a home pod i'm like one to seven
people in the world who own a homepod
i like um you know because it's not
something a lot of people really went
for
i love homepods i love the apple
ecosystem i was like you know what i
need to make sure
because you know with streaming i was
very vocal i worked for apple while
i was streaming and working for him at
the same time
and so while i was there um
i i was just like do i have like this
like like subconscious hate towards
android or are they really
like bad interest so so i got one
um because i i i did the switch from pc
to mac because you can't
you can't game on the mac like it's a
joke but like yeah i
i started streaming on the mac and i did
the nvidia geforce now
yeah that's what i screamed oh my gosh
scream does that i
went to kill him i was like i gotta we
like we gotta get you a series that's
something yeah
yeah yeah yeah in so uh
how well do how how stable is internet
uh
and we'd be like oh bro yep yeah we'll
be like hold on screw you got this today
we'd be right back hold on
it's like the worst just sneezed for a
second god yep
yep exactly so um so yeah i was like
i was just like so do i do i hate
android
hey i you know strong word do i dislike
android
because of android or do i dislike
android because i've been an echo
chamber of
uh apple is the best thing in the world
for you know all these years
so i bought i got this android phone
that's the s20
5g we have everything bells and whistles
ultra
um i like the camera
the camera and the display whenever i
want to play some destiny
the display is great the operating
system is bad no matter what skin you
put on it
i don't care that i can make my text uh
comic sans
your freedom you you're shackle-free
yeah it's like it's like well you can
customize your text it's like well yeah
i like things being legible though so
like
my preferred text is fine i've not like
i've tried to change it i went a week
and i was like uh my fiancee have been
watching all the marvel movies all over
again
so we got through like all like the we
we did a lot of we're finishing up we're
on the last two right now
uh but after seeing all of iron man
stuff i'm like a tech nerd and
you know so let me make my phone i was
like i can just go and just be like i
can make my phone like jarvis and so i
put up with that for like two days and i
was like yeah this is annoying i'm just
gonna go back to default
it's like things are actually just
really hard to read so i
just changed it back so back to default
look that i i give you credit because
most i mean obviously i'm an android guy
but most apple guys i know it's a it's a
line in the sand
and they are not even thinking about
going there so
to see this almost was like a choice
like you just like you know what i want
to
see what it's about so respect on that
because a lot of people yeah yeah
wouldn't wouldn't even
a lot of bible guys they're like this is
this is an apple home
well it it is it is an album still like
everything in here
like it you know um i can't say the like
the hey you know the word that comes
after yes yes
you know our favorite personal assistant
like they can't say that word in the
house or else you know turn on the line
it all works um this camera that i'm
like everyone's looking at me at like
like this is an iphone mounted like i
use an iphone
yeah i use an iphone as a webcam um
on that's on stream and everything um
and like i don't know i just like i like
i like it i just want to try out
android but i still wear my so where are
my apple watches
there you go
so they mostly got you you're just like
i'll experiment
yeah my experiment was not for much but
it's there it happened yeah
yeah yeah wait on the next one hopefully
you know better display comes out i'll
sweat you back you know
enough display gotcha that's all i can
supply yep
exactly well this is kind of a looter
shooter podcast but mostly
so back to the world of everything in
the week of destiny and we got
kind of a pretty awesome story beat this
week so i wanted to ask you guys
that's one of the biggest things that's
compelling a lot of people right now is
when you log in on tuesday seeing what's
gonna happen with the new quest
we got a new strike so we'll touch on
that first and then the story but
for when you guys went through you did
your little battlegrounds thing it's
like all right
we're going to the new strike so what
did you guys think of proving grounds
yeah yeah uh i like proving grounds a
lot
mm-hmm yeah um it i think
uh you know destiny does its best
whenever we have a good soundtrack too
uh think about all your favorite moments
in destiny there's usually a song that's
played during them that you're just like
actually i mean like a video game like
what other games you know like the name
of the song to
you know it's like it's so uh you know
the sepiks
uh redux he's hot right there
yeah i love him that's my it's my wake
up alarm that's my wife
uh and so i think like the music is what
really made the strike for me
just i like that i like the the
onslaught of cabal uh
you know it's it was just one of those
things where it's you know we're just
going up at it and it has a good story
it fits in so well it's not like you
know i've ran the arm sealer almost 50
times this weekend
you know through the grandmasters and
it's just like i don't really like arms
dealer
you know as a as a strike from the lore
it's like you know it was cool you know
we got to take down broncos on but like
yeah it just it doesn't have that like
triumphant
moment to it that proving grounds has
you know yeah
yeah man perfect guys nice nice surprise
i'm gonna touch
too much of story be sure i don't even
get into it but yeah it was cool man it
was definitely
cool to see a couple of unique things
and uh like like someone said like
i'm always a fan of just morka ball
every side every angle you know i'm
saying that overwhelming odd feeling
like
has been consistent with battlegrounds
which i really like so yeah i was all
about it man what about you
no i mean i enjoyed it and then kind of
leading in we'll get to the story in a
second
but it fit thematically because nessa's
i mean i go do my stupid serve videos
every week and you're like hey you land
on the
you they crashed a patrol zone for like
one of the first times in the game yeah
i saw somebody on twitter like i went to
the patrol zone and it had been like
five or six weeks into the season
they're like oh my god they changed the
zone like somebody hadn't seen it yet
and i was like
oh yeah it's substantially different
like it's like it is in the
battlegrounds and you've been seeing the
strike for like weeks and weeks in
battlegrounds and battlegrounds
right the funny thing was there was like
third fourth week whenever one of the
battlegrounds showed up
i glitched into that so i had seen like
the early intro because
it and it was like i was dying over and
over and it was that thing and i waited
long enough and they had most of like
flipped to the next checkpoint and all
of a sudden i'm just like
well i can't get out of here but i can
run around in here and you see like the
rotation of all the gears and everything
feel the cabal and the architecture and
stuff is still there and then as you go
through the strike you're like
you look down and you can see through a
window and they actually have like it's
probably a very repeated texture but
it's like you see the ground going by
that's right and then the treads like
that the dirt and everything it was like
just the thematic feel for one with the
story is awesome
but just how it felt like you were
inside a tank i was like they kind of
nailed it they did it they got a good
job
it doesn't have to be a huge strike but
just being like inside a tank everything
in there felt right
like right right and i kind of enjoyed
that and then the boss had like a pretty
unique mechanic because the first thing
i see him shoot is like eight of these
little trackies yeah i was like
fireballs and i was like oh god run from
those and they killed somebody
like the random person i was with they
died and i'm like okay run from those
cool check yeah
um yep and then you just see cover
moving up and down and i'm just sitting
there going through it and it's like
this is normal basic strike
like 1100 and i'm sitting there thinking
like you in the future i'm like
13 50 grand master i was like i'm going
gonna watch somebody do this because
it's gonna be interesting next week to
see so do
you have any big like worries about the
grand master or any certain rooms that
you see like trouble in
you know what i always go into
grandmasters for the first time uh just
completely just expecting everything
like expecting the absolute worst
um the only prep i really do is i make
sure like
i i like look back on it's like okay
like do i need sniper resistance
you know is there a lot of aoe do any
like a concussive dampener kind of thing
and then like what are the the shield
types since like arc solar void yep yep
after that like i don't i think it's
gonna be crazy
i like there's i mean you think about
like the rim with like the two tanks
like
everyone's like okay that's gonna be
that's gonna be bad and it's like i
don't know if it's gonna be bad though
because i've been dealing with two tanks
all week
and they're they're a joke but two tanks
at the same time yeah okay
so like maybe but
i don't know it's it's just one of those
things where it's like i'm i'm worried
about the cabal tracking orbs
because i haven't been there enough to
yeah
to see a lot there are things that will
track you when you're invisible
and there are things that won't track
you as invisible so like for example
like
uh in this week's gm when you have like
the slug gunners like they won't
they stop tracking as soon as you go
invis i'm hoping it's like taken
uh blight orbs that follow you but as
soon as you go invisible they stop
tracking you
yeah if they go if they stop tracking
you're good you're it's fine i'll be
okay
you know we'll we'll get some some great
carry numbers done it's palladrone week
baby it's going to be amazing
if they track you when you're invisible
you're trying to be doing exclamation
mark raffle and somebody
in somebody's chat and just calling it a
week no i'm kidding
but like it's gonna be it's just gonna
be it'll it'll be
a little crazy i'm looking forward to it
one thing i want to mention i know
we're going to get into more of the
story but i i did like the law
during the strike because there's this
back and forth
zavala exactly i was like we coming
through you know
like like you know she's going on and on
and her champion and this that
but even while it's going on i was still
getting a sense
of honor with kado and um you know i
i like that whole thing that you know
during the straight it was it was some
goods of all at her
banter she's actually been really good
right especially impressive
i like her impressions a lot as well
like what are you doing here you know
this is all business like you know
saying like it's just a cool
i'm really i know shout out to tassie
because he's been on the cable
bandwag he's been on that train since it
came in the stations before yeah yeah
and i was like wow and then now i'm i'm
starting to see it i'm like yo she's a
very
interesting character and it's just
really cool as we
tie into the next segment really cool
well
yeah like i mean that so you go through
you finish up the strike and
we get to finish this quest and it's
kind of like what's gonna happen so
right who wants to who wants to spill
the beans if you haven't seen it yet uh
sir
insane so as for those of you guys i've
been following you know like the story
of course like
you know aldrin's crow you know now crow
like that that reveal there of between
like the eye lock between him
and zavala was is huge you know that is
huge like zavala being like oh so you
are still alive
um and the fin you know i'll move on to
like how he feels about that afterwards
uh but then the more interesting fact
the lore
that we thought that you know we got on
twitter that cato did not call
in the scion you know the assassination
attempt that happened in the tower
that crow prevented the and then the the
new assassination attempt from the
scions
uh in this um this new cutscene
she's she is adamant she was she was
adamant on twitter
she's now adam in the cutscene that she
is
not calling in these these attacks so
that leaves the question like who is
calling his attacks you know
um you know it's just it's uh
very strange to me uh i love the
cutscene though
i that the eye lock between zavala yay
it's you know it was just it was
something it was it was a good one
powerful yeah i'm all about all above
the crow train all on it yeah all aboard
yeah but this this was it just because i
was behind this week so normally like
on reset i'm right in right there and i
think i jumped in maybe
thursday so i'm in a party with my guys
and
they're like i'm like yo before we do
banner let me i gotta catch up i gotta
you know it's the new episode
it's like season this is the box set you
know what i said tune in this week
so i'm like it's the new episode i have
to catch up so they like oh you didn't
do it i'm like no
so he's they i just muted them and
turned game volume
all the way up some people went all
right we'll do the tang okay go see okay
we go there we're doing this whole you
know the one-on-one the whole ritual
comment you send your best warrior
you know i'm like okay we're going
gladiatorial with it okay cool
so we get there and then you know crow's
there you know whatever whatever and
then
obviously these damn rogue science
that's not listening and
you know it really hit home because
you know one thing i like what destiny
did it reminded me of of cade's death
because like when you see
any of the guardians ghost in trouble
right you're like oh no they're about to
get by me
yeah yeah yeah exactly when you see a
ghost ghost
in time capacity yeah you like
oh no you know what i'm saying so when i
seen it and i'm looking at caleb's
reaction again we're going to see where
you at with this right now
right and then you know science is still
doing what they doing and then crow
jumps in and it's the classic moment
yeah it falls up and i actually
screenshot right there and i'm like oh
boy you're about to see some reaction to
what's going on here
right and um yeah just to see zavala
which i expected you know which i
expected
to just okay i i see who it is you know
what i'm saying right
the outstretched hand and then we got to
shout out kato she wasn't about that she
literally threw down yeah cuz i worked
grab money up ripped them up like doing
this
oh yeah
so i'm sitting there and i'm like okay
and it's it's it's so cool because we
got a respect factor and honor factor
and then obviously how you know what you
call it and how zavala i was curious to
see how he was going to take i
i anticipated he would take it fine due
to the fact that let's be real
we were all mad at him during forsaken
for a while there's a lot of
zavala hate because we're like yo you're
supposed to ride for cave
you didn't do this and then part of it
was like yo you know we're not
conquerors or not whatever so i think he
already accepted
the whole course of things and the fact
that he's a guardian he would be the
ones accepted but as we will
go on the talk after
hit a little bit for me if i could get
into that yeah absolutely
because um the thing about it is
one he's like all right y'all didn't
trust me enough
to tell me this right right you know
what i'm saying so he was not about that
he's like yo we're no different
from the enemy we face because we're
holding all these secrets and stuff and
another thing was
i call it new did y'all catch that yeah
yeah
he said that yeah
yeah so i guess she had a hidden and
everything and um
yeah that was interesting so i know
she's not going to play
a role much you know in this experience
and we know you know which queen is
where we get but to me
i need an i choral moment because at the
end of the day
i'll never forget what was she was like
we're not gonna she called zafala a
straight
cop she was like you're not gonna this
is coward like that
that scene was i don't i'll never forget
that that was cold-blooded and those two
been kind of icy
sits yeah so i'm very curious are we
gonna get that
aldrin in her and then remember we still
got amanda
remember amanda said some stuff in a
couple of battlegrounds prior which was
like yo i miss
kade he was great oh yeah he was awesome
i had love to
you know oh yeah we should come into the
city there's two people
he still have to you know kind of break
the ice with
it it's amanda in that court and i'm
especially icora
so oh yeah that that was my thing but
well done
bungie well done this was one of the
best
cut scenes that i really enjoyed it has
so many things to it so many moving
parts to it
and yeah man i was excited if they
they're doing this and again i know
we've we've had our issues with
battlegrounds
you know some feel is too long and
repetitive i get it but
when they do content like this this is
like dream content narratively for me
just you know you know what's going on
seasonal stuff
voice acting storyboard they're just
doing it and it's great to see so salute
to the team on it
yeah huge i mean like like think of like
pressage too like all of the stuff with
it's like you know i know we're talking
about the new stripe but pressage man
we're actually just mine
yeah yeah we did uh we did the flawless
master carries on that
and that was like i i feel like i know
the pressage inside out from that you
know i can run it with my eyes closed it
was
it's such a masterpiece and like the
dialogue there like the background i'm a
big
cyrus fan oh i know like right like oh
yeah you two just became best friends
yeah yeah i love osiris i know he's not
everyone's favorite
but i love osiris i'm curious i gotta
hate him
yeah yeah yeah talk about just something
he's just cool calm and collected
if bruce wayne was a guardian i think it
would be you know i think it would be
osiris he's just he's that kind of guy
he he doesn't follow the rules he makes
his own path and
usually you know screws up but like it's
fine
he's fine you know you know f in chat
for sagira but like yeah
seriously but i'm also a big saladin fan
as well so i'm glad that he's been
getting some
something those two have been a lot of
dialogue together too yeah i feel like
saladin has no friends anymore
like he's just cool he loses he's you
know it's like first he lost the iron
lords which you know poured one out for
the homies but like
then you know now he's fighting with
zavala he's fighting with osiris he
hates
crow it's like it just none of this is
just working out for him and so like i'm
kind of
i'm worried about a darker turn for
sally yeah yeah yeah
i'm worried about him especially because
bungie's been very vocal about how that
they want to like redo iron banner
you know give it a better reward system
like trials it's like
are we going to see like a you know
salvin kind of go more you know go play
with the drifter and kind of stuff like
what bro
you know darkest vanguard is he gonna
leave
i don't know he's been diametrically
opposed he
called zavala soft since he been in the
tower
he you know him and osiris had a little
bonding moment about maybe warriors
you know as opposed that and then the
funniest thing i still think the
funniest thing though is when
he's trying to discipline crow about how
he doesn't know anything and
you've got to learn and then crow
checked him with the most
subtly disrespectful one-liner i have i
thought it was elastic
he's like yeah so with all that you know
at the red wall i didn't i didn't see
you
yeah yeah exactly where was you at the
way he did
it and then he had no comments out of
that no come back
i was like damn that was cool yeah yeah
crow's
crow's been getting in those those
one-liners too i thought we were about
to see osiris backhand and whenever he
asked about like
he's like how did chase and or wrath go
for you i was like i was like
dude yeah he's got he's about to catch
it he reminded my man of the life
movement i was like lay down on the helm
man
oh dude crazy
honestly is setting a bar i hope they
continue it it's like the way it's i've
never seen them do anything honestly
like this they had the animated
storyboard a week or two ago which i was
like
i've been begging for that then we have
a cut scene like this in the same season
to see what's going on they're building
a villa
not really a villain though just an
antagonist who's like
potentially going to be an ally but we
don't really know
what's going on obviously you got the
rogue scions we don't know if they're
being
like tasked to do this stuff by somebody
else
is this like a zebra wrath or a
sabathune domino that they're trying to
set up to try and
you know break the guardians from the
inside there's a lot that's being set up
in the more and more when you go back
and you read
how they're trying to build a witch
queen to make these bigger story arcs
and go deeper into characters
if this is what we're getting started
with and we're not even which way now
like that's the point for me where i'm
kind of going
this is just 13. we still have 14 and
50. now we have no idea how long those
seasons are going to be they're probably
going to be a little long in the tooth
literally because of the delay
but still right if we get these type of
stories
while we go through these seasons and
then we get to
like witch queen and it's just like
crazy town oh my god
like this is the type of stuff that has
to be so excited because
you can only play this so i mean for
sherpas you guys can play until you're
blue in the face but like
right and that's kind of a thing but
it's like for some
if this is enough to keep people coming
back my question for you guys is
as of like cognitively never talked to
about this but for you
we haven't asked before how for you is
you play a ton
so you may not be as big to be like yeah
log on every week and do it
right for people who are you know less
hooked into the daily and the weekly
grind
of destiny how do you feel like the
story delivery has been do you feel like
it's in an okay place would you like to
see
because there's always the debate of
like the expansion just the here's like
the story dump and then you can go to
your activities or do you like the
the drip feed of the weekly or where's
your where's your preferred balance of
all of that
yeah um
it's it's one of those things so there
are some things i love drip fed
story like this i like drip fed i'm not
i'm not like a netflix fan where it's
like give me all the episodes at once
it's like
i really do like how like disney plus
did like one division and like
you know the mandalorian was like i
check in every friday i don't get
overwhelmed i don't feel like
you know because when everything's just
out there if you're on
you know if you're on twitter like a
good content creator yeah you're on
twitter
doing your due diligence you know trying
to just like some memes
they're gonna get everything ruined for
you you know like i haven't
i haven't even watched falcon the winter
soldier yet because i wanted to finish
infinity war
i already have like one major detail i'm
doing justice league while you're doing
that it's what you said that oh it's
just about the spoilers
yeah yeah it's just it's just like
you know and like you just can't there's
some spoilers that you can't like set
alerts for you know you just can't yeah
so it's one of those things where it's
like i like the drip feed content
because
especially as a sherpa it's like i need
to like i need to have the time to like
get people through the new raid and then
you know the new exotic quest and then
now grand masters it's like i like that
so there's a part of me that's like i
want grandmasters to be available at the
beginning of the season
yeah you know it's like just let us you
know let's try
you know but then there's like the other
part of me that's like well if
grandmasters are out there's a very
strong chance
that i'm gonna miss out on something and
the best example i can give is with the
pressage so every week
i was running the pressage as many times
as i could getting people through you
know
i was finding uh all the scannables i
did all the scannables
then like the the data pads there's one
everywhere they rotate
every week there's one i missed last
week's
why did i miss last week's because i
wasn't running pressage i had
you know either sherpa people do
grandmasters i'm really bad at taking
like that time for myself and being like
i got you
you know let's go do it so i think drip
feed just promotes like a healthier
balance to where like people
can kind of jump into the game get the
story
and then get the you know have the time
for like the rest of the activities
because like if something like
if it's a really good trials weekend um
i'll look at from the eyes of not a
streamer you know not someone who logs
in and plays
nine to five you know you log in you had
like a really long work week you know
you know you're working your 40 plus
hours and then it's like the weekend
comes and it's like all right time for
me to get some destiny action in
and it's like okay but the hand cannon
and trials is the three wins
so it's like well now i got to spend my
whole weekend say
yeah it's like you know i don't have
time to do the story i don't have time
to do the pressage this week i don't
have time to do
you know the grand master it's like i
was in a boat it's one of those things
it's like
i'm just trying to think of like i think
it does it i think it's a healthier
balance to where if we get that drip
feed story through the week because it
keeps people coming back in
you know it keeps everyone going and
everyone still has time to do the rest
of their stuff you know
yeah it's it's you're making some valid
points there i mean
it's different for for as the hardcore
for me it's different right
right because you know we're kind of
used to getting this huge
chunk and then you know having all this
time to digest it so to speak right
so now it's like okay they're i'm not
gonna lie there
when it because it's it's done well with
this lore and this story
that there is an excitement for me to
log in at reset
right and i haven't had an excitement
for reset in a long time
until this season shout out to paul das
he got a great article
about why he's here shows it's the best
season
you know i'm saying not expand just
season himself so um
yeah it's it's interesting and then it's
like like you said so
it's um you know grandmasters will start
or it's like okay hey i still gotta run
prep i still gotta run pressures more
because all i want is like a four-time
charm roll or a vocal roll i still they
keep giving me killing win every five
minutes
it drives me crazy i just so i want to
run that as well
um then i'm like with all the stuff like
you're saying that i need to be doing
right but then trials will be like yo
that's just this week
hey igneous heavens had three wins this
week all right i gotta get in there you
know what i'm saying
shout out to thai guy drivers is cool
they stomped the hell out of us in in
our trials but we ain't gonna get into
that
yeah it was crazy and they was tea
bagging they oh i didn't curse them
i was like look y'all bam y'all on
probation
yeah it's rules to this is honor but uh
we go we good that we all just said it
was fun it was fun just to see them
match up but um yeah it's just been so
much and then at the same time like i
know you're sharpering
you know there's a big content creator
one of my good friends randy outdoor
i finally got him to play death yes yes
yes
you're gonna play destiny with me and
we're going through the content and
stuff like that now we're up to shadow
keep
so it's like yo we got to get you to do
the dungeon we got to get you
you know we still got to do last wish so
it's still stuff to do
right and it it it's like i got thai guy
i see you in there
a part of that sir yeah they reported
they snitched on me
and they were they were unsportsman like
get your crew anyway
[Laughter]
i got to defend myself we got trashed
yeah man like at the end of the day like
it it i if done right
this could be a form if the key is done
right execute with story execute still
with content
i might come around but it it it has to
like eu made a good point they have now
raised the ball so high you can't go no
lower than this
as far as narrative like you've got
narrative
rocking right now and the last point i
make before i give it to you is
what's impressive about it to me is this
is during the pandemic
yeah you know we have to come on let we
got we know the railroad
we don't have that 200 000 foot square
foot studio built yet this is
working from home which is damn
impressive
yeah yeah so yeah yes no that's the kind
of thing
and it's this weird it's a
really hard line that they have to try
and walk and they're never going to win
all the battles that they like come up
against of how much do we give how
little do we give
this was seven weeks of like 13 week
season i think something like that
if you some people date a mine spoiler
you're not gonna miss too much at this
point
what's coming for um the rest of the
season
these first seven weeks were legit
right from here on we get guardian games
that's mostly all that remains
but i mean like the first seven weeks of
the story is really really solid like
really enjoying tuning in every week for
the episodes but then you're like hey
when's the next season of the show
we got more weeks to go now that's time
for some people to catch up and that's
where
where you solid when you're talking
about like pressage you miss
one week and for you it's like ah it's
like it's the balance of with the story
stuff people said if you miss weeks of
story and somebody in chat might correct
me if i'm wrong
you can catch up on the story you can do
multiple weeks of the story
yeah yeah so theoretically like if you
logged in this week
you would get your like full dump you
would get the full that sounds
awful but you would get like the full
show you would get the netflix binge
like if you logged in this week you
could literally go quest quest quest
quest question
you might like burn out on battlegrounds
to do it but
you would literally be able to go
through all the quest steps and get
everything in one step
and the difference is like when you say
pressage it's like i wish they would
kind of do some of that as opposed to
you got to do this thing 13 times and
it's like some of those if it's like
some people aren't gonna for one be able
to do master that many times
and then they miss out on some of those
things so it's like if you can get in
there just a couple like two or three
times
i like where it's like if you do the
scannables it's three weeks but if
you're saying the
the pads if it's literally however maybe
it's going to be 12 13
could take you like you know months to
do that that's the little bit of balance
where i feel like they need to work for
like
if it's just the datapad collectibles
it's not like hey you've done the master
you've
you've got your catalyst you got that
working to do go do that 13 more times
just for the data pads
most people are not going to do that
most aren't yeah unless they have
somebody unless they're like
sitting in your shoes and be like i'm
gonna run it anyway four thousand times
so i may as well drag others through it
but
the majority of people especially for
master aren't gonna go touch that stuff
so there's a lot of stuff they're
getting right and it's just those couple
balancing acts of i know they want
people to continue to have a reason to
play it
but especially if you're like i got my
killing wind or i got my subsistence
dead man's tail
why am i still going in here and most
people are going to be like i'm kind of
good
right yeah so it's that like yeah that's
like that's the hard line and they're
never going to get them all right
and it's like and it could be right in
your eyes you're like hey i love the
drip feed i'm going to do this every
week but now you're like i missed one
because of grand master and it's like
damn like
that somehow for you especially as a
sherpa playing as much as you are
you shouldn't be missing out on
something because i was doing some other
crazy activity that week there should be
the option for you to go get the stuff
you missed whether like
it's that and it's again it's like i
know it's going to be here for the next
like nine months
they're not taking anything away since
it stays in the game but then you turn
around and like
how many times are you really going to
go run like harbinger
it's sitting out there as a thing and
yeah it's a pinnacle i can do but
how many times do i want to go run
harbinger over and over and over again
like
there's a point where it kind of runs
out so it's that little balance of
giving the quests life but
not like really stretching them too thin
where you're like i get it i'm good like
too much
and it's but also for the seven weeks of
story i loved it
but is that do you turn around and tell
somebody like when you said randolph
thor
do you tell him to be like hey wait till
i see this last story beat
jump in we'll play next week you get to
go through everything and you can see it
all at once is that the better way to
tell somebody
or do you turn around and say hey jump
in every week we'll play for an hour or
two
and we'll do it you know like an episode
different people are going to want
different things and i kind of wonder
where they fall
yeah yeah no definitely sorry that was
very long-winded
no no you're good you're good oh yeah i
mean it's a really good point i mean i
like i still
have curse breaker because of like the
rotation of the curse weeks it's like
i think i think it's curse breaker
anyway i'm a title chaser i love the
title system
um you know that i could i could talk
for hours about the title system but
like the changes i would love to see
happen but you know there are just
titles i just like have to admit like
i'll never get
yeah and curse breaker is one of them
because the chances of me stopping
uh like the sherpa train to like jump
over and
go do like the curse week it's like i
don't know i haven't done a curse
thing and i don't know i can't even tell
you last time i was on a dreaming city
if it wasn't for a strike
you know yeah it's like yep i think come
on
yeah yeah i feel that i only time i'm
doing it it's like a
season of the hunt when i'm trying to
farm a um deafening whisper or something
like
that i forgot those were still a thing
yeah yeah you still did yeah
you're still out there yeah monster
forever that's why you uh aldr
uh aldrin slash crow crow crows on uh
two separate places
yeah yeah yeah stuck he's in somehow
made a clone of himself so but that's
like
you see the way the story is delivered
this time they set the bar really high
and i'm like i don't know what the next
season's gonna be but
man we're in for a fun couple of seasons
but again i wanted
like how long do you think these next
two seasons are going to be because we
get
may so we got seven months left in the
year if they go early you're like
eight nine months for two seasons like
four and a half months a season that's a
long season it's a long season yeah and
if we have like a story that lasts seven
weeks
that's like a third yeah yeah
yeah i mean i can promise you one thing
festival of the lost is not gonna get
the crimson day treatment because we
take out
if we take a festival to lost it's gonna
be a really long year
oh man so like i don't know like it's
i'm optimistic you know i'm hopeful for
some good story i'm hopeful
for some good activities i mean we're
gonna get vault of glass coming you know
vaulted classes next season that's gonna
be huge uh
we got transmog coming you know like
there there are things that are gonna
keep it spicy that we
know about that aren't even story
related yet yeah cross playing as well
too
yeah you know there's so many good
things coming out before that next
season so
i don't know i feel like this is where a
lot of people and this is what i said
whenever beyond light got delayed he's
like this is nothing but good news
this just means there's gonna be a lot
more wayfarer running wayfarers running
a lot around like
you have more time now to get those hard
to get achievements that you didn't get
before
you know like it it's just one of those
things you have more time to get those
collectibles more time to get those
scannables
you know more time to do all these
activities before you know they might
wrap up
you know personally i know a lot of
things are staying longer now thankful
for the new
uh you know anti-fomo thing what they're
doing absolutely
but i mean like there are still things
they're going to be heading towards the
content vault
as we get closer to which queen coming
out you know things are going to get
vaulted so we have to get ready for that
um so i think there's just gonna be a
lot more people you know
polishing off those achievements before
or the time
yeah yeah i'm not too worried about next
season i think my thing is just like
again now that we know
which queen has delay like he's saying
like how would they
handle that extra buffer with content
then
later in the year i want to see how they
what what's the plan
for the team to extend you know so to
speak so yeah that's good but like you
said
more time to do stuff more time like i
said get your titles whatever and the
cool thing with the seasonal model
is i have to be honest the reason why i
like it as a gamer i'm able to still
play destiny and get other games
completed and finished and it's just you
i'm in this nice balance because i have
a rule in my house
like if i'm trying to get anything done
destiny cannot go on first because if
destiny goes on
first i am living in destiny
it's just it's just the nature of the
game when it's you know it's such a
hook and then your friends are on and
then it's just this whole tidal wave
of you know trying to do stuff and and
get things done or help people
whereas you know when i'm kind of like
okay i did everything this week
i'm caught up on story all right now i
can try this game or this thing that i'm
trying to finish
and i've been more productive so i'm in
this kind of half for me personally i'm
in this happy medium
where i'm still playing destiny right
but i'm still able to get other things
done when i finish the kind of things
that i want to do so
yeah well i like it so far we'll see how
it continues
you know so question for you sublets
have you touched out writers
man oh this question
yeah um not touched out writers i looked
i watched uh i watched some some of my
friends you know
i stream it and play it i ultimately
decided it's not the game for me
you know really yeah not
i'm not a gears of war fans so like let
me just throw that out there never was a
gears of war fan
um it shares a similar art style gears
of war
it's third person like years of war the
whole cover system i mean i never played
um
division that much either just because
like i don't i just don't like
third-person games
okay got it so that that was like a big
turnoff for me
to begin with but that was like ah but
come on like it's gonna have like
you know like weapons and magic and like
cool stuff like that
but again the reason why i don't like
world of warcraft like world of warcraft
has great lore
like amazing lore in world of warcraft
but the art style i
just i can't get past take anything so
is it the art style also here you can't
get past or is it more
that it has cover yeah it's the third
person aspect
it's like the cover kind of like
mentality kind of thing where it's like
cover like
tilt to shoot and stuff like that and
then like it's also the art style as
well
it's like i think everything i think the
like
i think the the classes i think like the
skill lines and stuff like that i think
it looks solid i think it looks like a
great game for people
that like that kind of stuff but for me
it's just it's not going to be one of
those games that i pick up
i would say this because me and you sh
i literally was there the first
like all the trailers coming in and i'm
like i don't think i'm into this you
know what i'm saying
and i i'm not i don't hate gears but
you know coming you know cover coming
from destiny right cover makes you feel
a little
restricted right right so i will
say this what i will say still advise
you to at least try the demo
for the simple fact that you really
don't need cover okay
like the way that game plays
you can play run around hectic
and it's different in that respect right
the the the meat and potatoes of the
actual gameplay loop
is actually pretty fun okay i'm with you
in our style i'm not necessarily sold
there
i'm not i'm not i think their faces look
like playstation 3 i got
i just certain aspects are the graphics
and the law i'm not
going to get over i'm with right there
yeah right but
the fundamental core gameplay in loot
mechanics
and trees the depth of the trees once i
picked the character i found the
character i like it it was a techno what
is it technical answer yep
technomancer once i cuz i tried the pyro
and i was like i don't like i was really
going through this game with a bunch i
was like oh i'm done i'm never
and someone begged me just try another
class right and i'm like all right
the game was uninstalled i reinstalled
it
i was like all right jessica fairness so
yeah like just so someone doesn't call
me i'm like oh i looked at that [ __ ] you
already played the power you lied you
know
all right i will try it once i got here
yo shout out to the door he said
technical voice for life
you know so it's like i tried it that
was the connection for me
so i would say try it with a friend
mm-hmm
trout try it just try the demo right
yeah i mean it's free right
yeah yeah it's not going anywhere right
right worst case and if you end up
liking it it's still free again in game
pass if you want to you know
rock out you know what i said so that's
all i was going to say give it one more
shot i would say with a cloud
just to see it still may not be for you
but until the second thing that's
that i said i was like yeah i i get it
now i get it now yeah i mean like i gave
warcraft i mean so many chances i've
played warcraft so many times too so i
i i'm no stranger i can give a game a
chance yeah you always get i'm always
i was like full disclosure ambassador um
so it's like my opinion might be a
little biased put your cardboard
on put your clothes on let's go hold on
all right
there we go there it is let's talk about
the greatness
yeah no there's way too much strawberry
lemonade i've had recently it's a
problem
um no but like for me
with i've never played gears up until
five
i tried five because it was on pc game
pass right
and even for me the story was told in a
cool way but i did
not love like the gameplay the cover
like being stuck i just
that didn't hit for me either so i was
like gears is one of those for me now
grant i play the crap of the world so
you can take all of this with a giant
grain of salt so that's different sure
um but i will definitely tell you like
different people are going to mold with
different classes and if you don't want
to play cover
try devastator or tech or trickster
those are your two
i think that's true behind cover and
trickster for you if you like assassin
and you like mobility you like minecraft
bro i would probably say like if you get
a chance if you can find non-sharpening
stream time
take like a couple hours try the
trickster get a couple
and the problem like i will tell a lot
of people and i've tried to say this in
the videos i've made about it
most people will not get a chance to
play the demo enough and probably not
like
go through the farming loop a little bit
to get where
your abilities change because the big
thing is you'll
there's eight total abilities you get
like four in the demo so you can mess
around a little bit
but the big thing that changes it is
armor so each armor has like a mod and
if you get rare ones you get one mod
in the full game you'll have two mods
and then legendary it's crazy
but the mo like if you take five pieces
of armor
and i did this for my devastator and
every one of the mods is for
one ability holy crap it's not even the
same
so like i can take like so the
devastator has one called reflect
bullets
right so you can normally like pull it
up you're like
neo you're just walking around catching
all the bullets and at the end you throw
them back you're like okay fine
that's pretty cool yeah i was like
that's actually kind of fun you don't
take any damage while you're doing it if
you're in a group guess what you're the
one up in front you're like the you know
titan shield walking around and then you
just throw all the bullets back at
whoever's in front of you
so then i add all the mods on top and i
can i can now it auto does it so it auto
bounces them back while i can still fire
every every bullet does like 25 more
damage
the person with the highest health in
the room takes 50 percent more damage
it lasts like 30 percent longer
yeah all of that combined there's like
one boss room i can go into
i literally like load in the room and
again i've like probably over farmed the
demo but there's like one side quest i
can beat like the captain in the room
three seconds dead now did i start with
that field no
but i was like if you like the idea of
pve which is kind of your jam you're not
much of a pvp person
if you want to feel a point like because
that's one thing about destiny that is
has always been a struggle the feeling
of rpgs yeah feeling powerful you never
get like
i want to feel like a crazy busted god
mode right now right and this game will
get to that point
because they did one on twitter where
they talked about this like fire witch
one of their abilities is down to like a
six second cooldown
like that's like unheard of for dusty so
i would probably say try the trickster
yeah that sounds like the one i would
say for you to try
yeah and then if you play the demo
because what you can do is like you can
go basically to the end of the demo and
then go back in the story
and then continue to play through it a
couple times do like side quests you can
repeat
and once you get kind of enough blues to
really change up your abilities then
if you at that point you're like still
hate it cool right like that would be my
recommendation for it
and i feel like 60 hours in this demo so
i'm crazy
also one last uh point of advice because
you're like me when you rolled your eyes
on certain parts
take violent games we had on that's a
good point
don't take the story seriously that's
what i learned to not roll my eyes
because there was something
so i was like narratively because for me
i always feel i need to connect
you know what i'm saying right with the
characters or whatever whatever
and once i start like just say okay
they're not taking themselves seriously
right now right so i'm just gonna be
relaxed a little bit and then i was able
to get through a lot of but yeah
trickster for you i would say just give
it one shot with that and after that if
that's still like hey
walk away you did what you had to do
yeah i mean it's definitely like
especially
i mean you pointed out with destiny it's
one of those things where they just
haven't hit that kind of stride like
there's not
a destiny mode where you can be like
like
you know it's terrorizing everything
yeah it's like you know what after doing
like
so many you know grand master carries it
would be nice of my decompress routine
it's like
let me just you know open up a sweet
business and just mow down some like
some hive
you just can't do it you can't do it
it's still gonna take you like seven
minutes to
kill it you know to kill thrall or
something it's crazy
no like i've been doing this i killed
their god and they still don't instant
die
like yeah that's come on good point good
boy
uh and then you got full cr that one
does actually have full cross play
so if that's something you actually
enjoy doing and you're like hey i want
to sharpen people through like in-game
expeditions
if it actually hits for you full cross
play is actually going to be there so
that one i'm very curious to test out to
be like hey anybody want to jump in
here's
code first people in come on and that's
like that's kind of a cool thing that's
seeing like the idea of that cross play
has been hyped for what crossplay is
going to be in destiny for that exact
same reason to just say
open the gates and everybody gets to
come in yeah bro we got it being easy we
got to test that bro we got so
good no absolutely sure i really want to
do that with you we gotta
i know our schedule's been crazy but we
got to lock that down
for sure play night multiple glasses
when it's got to be for sure volkswagen
at first oh yeah absolutely yeah so uh
sp
you mentioned vault of glass is kind of
like kind of a special nugget uh
where are your like top three because
this is that podcast
for raids what are your what are your
your highlights of the raid chart over
d1 and d2 where do you where do you rank
your top
man oh man i mean like slang oryx i
think is like always gonna be like
i think it's just gonna be that's gonna
be number one i don't know my my cat's
name is oryx uh oh well okay so
well like that's a personal opinion yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so i also i feel like i can't hurt
their feelings i have to mention the
other one so i also have an australian
shepherd his name is gambit
uh named after the game yeah yeah
yeah so so i have to mention both of
them
second uh second raid of all time would
probably be last wish i'd love to take
it
um yeah you see you see this guy right
here behind me oh yeah
i'm very strong with my like my loves
and so like my channel whole theme is
like purple because of void
and like 10 like the tendon kind of like
gooeyness of like venom so it's like
those two
mixed together like that's like okay
let's see that um
so that's last wish and then number
three is actually deep stone crypt
um and that's yeah yeah yeah
like i guess it's not hard raid it's not
i mean like it's for some people it
might be hard but like it's not like a
super hard raid you know like it's not
like uh
it's not like a last wish yeah um give
me the moment
but it's so good with like that lore
like the lore
like when you're driving in uh you know
on the sparrows you can see like the
tower that all the exos like have their
nightmare about
and like you're learning all about
clovis and it's like i wasn't really
connected with like the whole clovis and
like the whole bray family thing
um but after that i was like that that's
a good one
i mean the moments though what was the
moments in deep stone crypt that you go
yo oh my gosh you know
i remember like um my team we were doing
so well day one we were doing so well
i'm gonna hype them up they were doing
an amazing job on day one we
were killing it we were like we were
contending
until we hit the eight tracks
same thing i was there
and then now everyone's like well
everyone was contending into late tracks
it's like well yeah but like
like we were ahead of like a lot of like
the the top people um
through security like we got security
down like that nice
but when we hit a tracks it was a
struggle bus um
and when you get done with when we
finally got done with aatrex
and then you just hear the one piano key
it's like it's honestly it's like the
the starting for the black parade
uh from my chemical romance like you
know that piano key
and it's like yeah it's like exactly
it's like that moment was like i'm gonna
cry
i'm gonna cry i don't know if it's
because i'm tired or if it's because
like
at that point probably it was both but
that moment was just
beautiful but yeah i i think oryx just
because of like everything that came
with
i mean it wasn't oryx you know like
everything that came with them
and then uh and then last wish also just
all of last wish is great like
everything's
bad i can't get married at the end of
the
like i said regardless of my biases like
those are strong choices i i can't it's
cool to see
you're the first to put deep stone in
the mix we all fit we all
feel it's up there you don't feel you're
out of bounds for it i just feel like
it's cool to see how the effect of it
because i
admit you know now looking back i
still enjoy running it like i could
always tell that's it was one of those
things
it reminds me it almost reminds me of
the machine from
d1 in a way where it was a raid that
may have not well deep still got a lot
of epic fair to it but
it's one of those i could always judge
the raid well how many times
i continue to still do it afterwards
well i still enjoy it it's one of those
things though it's like
well think about how many times you ran
leviathan though you know
it's like it was the only way i would
bring that i would still would dread
leviathan i would drink exactly
dogs i would dread gauntlet and i'm just
like ah
the only ones i didn't dread with you
know the bats
and the fight the actual fighting stuff
i like when somebody go i got a
checkpoint
all right cool i mean that's like good
yeah
but he's like oh we gotta sneak around
then we gotta do american ninja warrior
for this dude
bro like i gotta do it like i think my
only issue with it was just that
the cholesterol what is the calisthenics
what's the drug before the challenge no
no
before you actually go to each encounter
the correct way to do it the leviathan
the costello
the costello right yeah so it was just
okay you're doing that and
so when they found out how to do the
underbelly and then just get to the
counter i was like okay
cool right but i just wish it needed
more
another boss encounter instead of
shooting chandeliers
running from dogs and like that kind of
stuff that's it right but um
yeah with deep stone like you said you
know only nitpicky
i felt like the the i love the idea of
the sparrow going in you know what i'm
saying
i felt that mechanic was a little rough
i was like damn hey really you gotta
freeze the death
okay cool once we got in
like you said security nice good at
first encounter okay cool
eight tracks broke us all but once we
learned it eventually
okay cool and then i'll see the moment
right yeah
and what i don't think gets enough
credit
is actually the the the first tanex
encounter
right with the hecticness yeah i love
the music i love the outside of the ship
you're spiraling
you feel the tension and that music
you start everybody oh get your hook up
the scale is going off all right which
one like it's just
we play we call it like yo everyone just
call it chaos mode no matter what role
you play that's what we call it
yeah we got chaos everyone grabs a roll
and it's so
fun it's just it's just a a release
right of pure hecticness
and then obviously my only nitpick
obviously we've talked about this before
you know it was 10x i'm like okay 10x
again but
right i love the fact that it brought it
back to the beginning of the raid
right the beginning that you crashed
right where you started at
kind of thing and then you know the loot
was was was very rewarding so
i went so good some of the best loot in
the destiny rate i have to admit like
the
the new perks everything so now i'm with
you man i i cannot get mad at someone
who has deep stone [ __ ] as they're uh in
number three so respect your list i
respect it right good
it's good that's strong less strong
listen
won for me just because of again and you
build from crota you go
through like you've got boss fights and
that was when i was probably still
writing the most i haven't rate it as
much probably since then because a lot
of my friends fell off same principle
um but that was one whereas like if i'm
in a certain point i'm on the origin
side i'm on my titan i'm just like
i'm running the ball like i like like
when i when i had encounters where i was
like
i'm running this [ __ ] or i'm
coordinating this stuff and i'm like
yeah okay i'm gonna sit on like gold
growth i'm like also low the top u5
jumped down i got to the point where i
was like i got my machine gun i'll take
care of everything like
that was still one of my favorites
exactly like if you could solo gogograph
you're like i'm just you're ahead on
damage anyway because you got five
instead of four down so
like that one's still special to me and
for i'm a weird one because i like
crota's end
you like i like crotazin because for one
it's one of my best friends we did
two man flawless and two i always
thought thematically
it could not they could not have nailed
like after a vault of glass
to go high raid and they just it felt
right
thematically to like nail the fr the
frantic nature in the beginning
you got the sword moments with the slams
and then the big giant eye in the
background
it just had some cool p and everybody
calls it like a strike and i'm like
i still i enjoyed that one i was like
everybody
a lot of people be like hey that thing's
like a strike i'm like it's a bit more
kill the strike
yeah i was like so i'm being nice today
i'm gonna let you have the moment
yeah bring me in bring me in we did it
today
on stream actually yeah
yeah i was like it just felt
thematically but it was just like also
one of those like
that's where i got my flawless raid for
my like platinum on playstation i was
like and then probably three for me is
like i don't know you like there is
something about that deep stone crypt
walk lately
for me now i don't know if it's like the
whole raid because i haven't rated it as
much
last i'm not saying this i'm just saying
like
moment in raid there's not a lot as he
said when you take
when the music muffles when you're like
your gunshots are muffled when you hear
just like that
song in the moment again 8 tracks was
like 12 hours for me and then finally
when i got through it i was just like
you're like so relieved and it's just
like it hits so perfect i'm like
that may be one of the one of one of the
best i don't know if it's like the best
but that may be one of the
just best moments on a raid of just like
the peace and serenity and the music
and like you're out in space like i
don't know if the raid for me like i
still haven't got a ranking but that
moment alone is just like oh yeah
so that's one of the yeah i don't think
there's anything like it like
we've had like that that sad serenity
and you're talking about
hive i'm just sitting here i'm like
thinking i'm like man like have we had
like a really good hybrid in destiny 2
yet and it's like we haven't
like like savathun's coming that's the
one thing is coming like that that's
gonna have to be it's like krausara was
cool but like yeah that wasn't yeah yeah
that's not
you know come on no i'm with you i'm
which yeah i'm with you there
and like i said we we were lucky enough
to have uh skye
lewin on for the bungee audio and uh
yeah like that that moment like lullaby
is just something magical it's just
magical bro it's just it's nothing
that's a moment in destiny history to
this day like when that might you
feel something when that that thing
happens but yes a little bit
can't go wrong with these choices man
it's good to see you know the raids
kind of getting the love finally that
they deserve so to speak you know
yeah racers going outside that's fine
shout out to the fast and furious by my
house
golly i love you oh so good um yeah
but outside of that like i mean we had a
small patch this week we had
you know the matchmaking changes done i
didn't know if you guys played because i
played iron banner on day one on tuesday
knocked out all my quests and i haven't
touched it since and then as of
i think it was literally the early
thursday twab said
hey we're switching the way the party
balancing is going i have seen some
mixed stuff on twitter about this
so i wanted to see if you guys have
played iron banner maybe not you
slutledge because you've been busy
but cognito or and what you've heard
from your community as well as you go
through i'm curious like
what you've heard where things are
standing because i've seen people like
five matches in a row either getting
stomped or 30-minute matchmaking like
it's
it doesn't from what i've seen seems
questionable
oh yeah you peeped up fast and furious
yeah yeah yeah
i did the fast appearance i'll jump
i didn't i'll i'll defer to sullaj if
he's tried
crucible more recent have you tried like
iron banner recent because i see i
played
around wednesday before that thing went
live right
i want to before we get into that we
have to pull one out for the homie
stasis right now i got my stasis shirt
on
yeah but bro i got my shirt right here i
just haven't worn it yet so i just
when i knew something was up it's who's
my man that does the amazing tick tock
d flawless
we gotta get you in the last word too
bro yeah seriously so
i saw it i'm like i knew something's
cause i'm playing banner with the homies
and i'm like hmm i haven't felt annoyed
yet
yeah like you you you play enough
against stasis where you like you just
roll your eyes and you know oh my god
you know kind of thing
and i'm like i'm kind of killing these
dudes
easily and i'm like yo and i i mentioned
to
the party i'm like to the clan i'm like
bro is it me or these stuff these stasis
nerfs are kind of hidden because
i'm not really cursing about it right
now so then we go in and i'm like
yo i'm not you know to get sucked bro
dust grenade
that's [ __ ] ain't catching me you
know the shadow diving is crazy
i'm outpacing people and i'm like i
think punchy's got it
you know i was just we had so much fun
we were wrecking it felt like old times
now granted did i get frozen once or
once
a couple of times yeah absolutely but i
remember even breaking
out easier and i'm like with a less
penalty
just a little subtleties and i'm like yo
this
is okay so my experience as far as the
stasis nerves and the effects of that
felt great now as far as the matchmaking
prior
you know again i can only go by i
haven't tried the new stuff i'm dying to
know
what people are saying because they just
recently added this patch and i guess
it's about you know number one it's
gonna you know number two doesn't go on
it's like a
a tier system kind of thing or whatever
they're doing so i'm curious to see how
people are saying
that's going for them and again i don't
know if some of you you've done that so
i'd refer to you guys
on that and what you got at least what
you guys are hearing because i i don't
know what the new
matchmaking feel is now that they just
added that
what do you guys think i mean this is
this is something i'm planning on
looking into tonight
um so i can throw up my article and
stuff on it because i i honestly i
haven't had time to
to do it to play into iron banner um or
to play with the stasis nervous that
that hurts me
a lot um i'm with uh you know fitzy
uh i'm all about it dude like i'm an
iron lord through and through like i
love the lore i love it i got
uh i got cons um uh iron lord gym shirt
i love the iron lords man
like yeah see our podcast
yeah and then yeah yeah your guys
youtube channel and everything it's like
iron lords a baby like i'm all about it
i love it and i'm just not playing iron
banner anymore man like it's just
there's i don't want to bring it up
because i don't know it'll be like
another hour long
say it nope say it iron banner needs
like a whole rework
and like i know some of it's coming it
needs a title first of all back like
my god iron lord young wolf like we got
two
two easy titles like easy just throw
them at me there like at least like i
know like we are we're already called
young wolf and
you know et cetera et cetera but just
throw it at us like
you know and uh so there's so there's
that
and then like capture like i hear not
control is a consistent game mode in
destiny that it does not go away
it doesn't vary it's the easiest you
know pinnacle for you to get at the
beginning of the week
you're always in control right why is
iron banner the limited time game mode
control oh like always controlled
easy i don't know uh so i i haven't
touched it
um people were bringing it up in stream
today though while we were running some
runs and they were talking
about they were saying i had one one
folk come in and say
you know it's been a cuban for 45
minutes
uh some of that like it's like some
really long queue times and i don't know
you know
we all you know especially in the texas
fans we all exaggerate you know
you know it's like five minutes been
like an hour
yeah yeah we haven't had it raid in six
years
you know it's so like there's that so
people are saying like they have these
really long queue times they have other
people are like i haven't noticed a
difference at all in the queue time so
like i don't know if it's like a network
thing or what's going on but i will say
i do like the the schoolyard draft kind
of thing where it's like you know
you know cog's obviously going to be
number one the other team i'll be in
there you know just like in high school
i'll be at the very bottom of the pick
list
so it's like destiny always keeping me
in check so
you know it's like that would be
hilarious is like as you're loading in
it actually puts you on your team so you
see where your skill falls you're like
number 12 we have a bonus coming on the
b
team it's like oh yeah yeah you ready
for them to call your number
yeah you would see a lot more tea
bagging though
because yeah number 12 kills number one
one time oh
yeah it's gonna look like uh like a lift
in factory in there
so yeah i don't know i'm excited to see
it though i didn't want to play it
e uh i'm trying to pull up new rad's
tweet
right now actually because he literally
was just like trying to tweet back
at now i'm trying to find it um
literally his was just like i think he
was in like queue for 45 minutes it was
just
his was ridiculous so um
yeah he said he said the new matchmaking
system sucks i've been sitting in over
30 minutes waiting to get the same game
going
it hits 12 people and then probably goes
back to one
and if it does work more often than not
puts me on the ass end of a fight
of a effing 4v6 with no joins the entire
damn time
oh no that's pretty awful so i didn't
think
sample size of one obviously so it's
like it is hit or miss
but uh yeah that's not great
i was like when i played on tuesday i
had
i mean i had some mercies and i had some
sweaty games but at least like the
matchmaking didn't feel
i didn't have anything like 30 minute
matchmaking or anything along those
lines
it is weird like the freelance playlist
um
and i think this is another reason i
can't wait for cross play like freelance
gambit somebody's like oh you're just
going to like set you know
cut the lit cut the matchmaking down
even farther i'm like crossplay is going
to fix that like when
crossplay comes freelancers throw it
everywhere
especially yeah game everyone needs a
refresh iron banner 100 iron banner at
least has freelance
sometimes though man i am i do need to
go back and try it though because he
said the schoolyard system
there are times you like you'll go in
and it just it's
something about iron banner when you
lock them
it snowballs really fast if one team
gets ahead early
i had one it was like you know 77 to 11
and i'm just like good god and i was
like
but on the other side it was also like
20 to 90.
you know and it's like okay so the
swings are so big and
but as you said it's like how many times
are we going to play control and the
only devil's advocate i'll say
when they tried to switch away from
control whether it was d1 or whatever
they could complain
i'll see you next week until you come
back to control and i'm like you don't
want to like you know you have like
every month or something of a season
like control can
you tell me one of those months can't be
something else like that
at least a little variety even for
bungie to be like hey this is going to
be the clash one just to get a feeling
just something different mind it i
didn't mind clash especially rift
you need a little variety but the main
thing too is just like man
that'll be crazy you'd finish it about
he's faster for the love of god
yeah and they're still with the weapons
man wait well you know
with the recycled you know okay i'm fine
with the weapons honestly
okay for the most part for okay i'm not
fine you like the give and take perks
though like that's a weird thing
it's such a weird thing but
what's up with the armor man facts
i complain about this all the time i
have
the picture somewhere on my on my
desktop i complain about this all the
time it's like
you bungee's okay with like bringing
back old armor sets and stuff like that
like the trials of osiris
the one why has the hunter wolf pelt not
come back
like why can't i wear the wolf pelt
again like where's my furnace chest
stuff
yeah like where's all of this great
armor i want
it's like with the remember yeah the fur
it's like you can bring back the you
know all of these like the iron will set
like seven times but you can't bring
back the
like you can't bring back a d1 armor set
once like yeah
just at least give me that like i would
be fine with the weapons
and stuff like i will say the weapons
have been weird where it's like you know
criminals dagger is this 120 and then we
have um
uh what's the other one steady hand
steady hand's the other 120 but it's
carmilla's dagger but it's not
carmilla's dagger yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like i don't know man it's
they they gotta figure something out
with the weapons but they they
definitely need to
take a look at the armor in the game
mode too it's like still needs a
complete rework
i'm almost i'm i'm with you let's double
down so
let's just go like a let's do like a
iron
banner theme season or iron lord season
that's what i'm saying let's get a salad
in season let's rework
banner right let's do the titles
everything you're talking about let's
have a nice nada
maybe bring siva involved but that's
just me yeah
and really commit and it's just like
they're just playing with it they just
you know let you jump in for a minute
they're not doing anything with it and
the bit like you said the biggest
offender is the armor
that i remember there was a sense of
like
eagerness back in iron ban and when
you're like yo i gotta get to set i
gotta get the boots i gotta get them you
know
it was a thing and it's just like this
is like challenging
siva armor and iron banner i would lose
my that would be oh incredibly amazing
maybe that's it maybe that's salad and
snap like maybe he's like you know
zavala's lost is mine you got guardians
playing with darkness you got
like maybe that's it maybe it's like the
only thing that will fix this world is
siva and it's like
all right fine let's do it let's get it
open let's go
give it a vault where it got locked away
and just like let that crap run free
let's let it go
crazy man let it go i'm waiting so much
potential
yeah that's that's like i mean for pve
people especially you got grandmasters
now you got a debt blood in there but
man pvp people still
when you see they make tr they make
trials as its own thing but they make
iron banner like
hey iron banner it's the you know the
events of the month or whatever and it's
like
really this is like what you're
presenting on the silver platter for
salad salad has had more awesome stuff
happen in the story
in this season than he's had in probably
all of destiny 2 for any
iron banner because 100 facts yeah it's
like
uh and then you know the intentionality
of the loot we now have umbrella engrams
where you can go after and you're like i
don't have anything like that and i know
i'm like
either tassie or there's 20 like
probably 20 people have said this one
kuje has done like a lot of cool stuff
with it and everything so you've got
a lot of people who have these ideas and
some of them are not like
huge fixes like just the iron umbral in
just
just give that a little choice of hey
what do i want to go after as opposed to
let me throw my tokens at
this you know crap well and see what
sticks so yeah
no it's like i always have about 13 1213
tokens i'll throw a few in the you know
slot machine pull it out and see what i
get and be like oh it's fine
yeah but overall it's like nothing's
exciting and then you get this like iron
reach you're like cool
i have like 50 stability or i'm 50 range
on an smg with five stability i'm like
how is it even that low it's like it's
going to kick like a mule so
yeah yeah those are the the whole give
and take perks is one of those things
when i
when you do go play like an outriders do
you go play a pv game it's like oh
you're god mode right now i'm like
man destiny can you catch up just just a
little bit here please yeah just a
little bit yes
that's those moments where i will i will
truly say like
there's one thing you need to play out
riders for if nothing else just to
experience the auto loot system
yeah that'll load that's a quality of
life thing because you can choose like
when you leave an arena
what what rarity do you want to auto
pick up
right and you can also hit a button to
do the same thing and it's just like
please like the blues because when you
play iron banner you're just like
thin and blues blues because if you're
playing enough matches i'm like i don't
need any more
yeah the little quality of life stuff
that again that's why my eyes keep
looking out to
witch queen because i know seasons can
only do so much it's like the big system
changes to hope for
so as we kind of wrapped up this episode
that's kind of what i wanted to ask you
guys um
what are a couple things that you guys
are whether it be systems or anything
you know kind of tapped on iron banner
but what are like
two things we'll kind of go around robin
that you would like to see
come witch queen that far out because
a little smaller but what are some big
stuff that you'd like to see
you know come february 2022 or whenever
the hell it's going to drop
sir guest you are first well give me
give me one
give me a b if you don't have one i'll
go to cognito if i put you on the spot i
have
i have a huge one but i just want to
make sure i'm like hidden in the same
ballpark
so this is like any feature to come to
this yeah complete like just
destiny 2 game open open field here
yep all right this is actually the
easiest question in my life
number one the easiest one as a
community person
for first and as a sherpa i we need
a better clan system we need i mean
crossplay is coming
you know there are amazing guardians in
the world you know amazing guardians out
there
we all don't fit on the 100 man team you
know and a lot of people like to rally
around the banner you know
people like you know they love uh you
know the flag you know we
i just i think it's important that we
have a better clan system we need a clan
space
you know uh warframe does this really
well where you can have like that ship
you know and decorated and all that
stuff
uh a lot of mmos have like clan houses
and stuff like that it's like we should
have that you know if my
you know if i have a team from my clan
that participates in day one like
there should be a banner hanging up in
the hall of that you know there should
be boss trophies i should be able to
mount oryx's head onto a wall
you know nice i should have tannics like
if i if i can't wear tanix's cloak i
should
very surely have it hanging you know
from the ceiling or something like that
it's like
we just need like this better sense of
community in the game
to where we can all rally together hang
out and we don't you know we don't to be
doing
activities i think 12 man's really
showed us that
those were so fun right like we love
just being together as a community and
there's not really anything that you can
do that on if you don't want to run a
raid
you know yeah so that's that's that's
where i'm at that's that's my number one
there oh that's an easy answer for you
what about you yeah oh that's a big
that's that's a sigh and a half right
there yeah uh
the true commitment to pvp the yeah
the truth the show that you show the not
the words again
i don't want to hear about you know
we're listening i'm tired if you're
listening
to pvp you know granted yeah you know
charles weapons have been a little nicer
we know i feel about it that but
you know pvp as a whole is just i mean
we haven't gotten a map
in like whenever you know it it's just
i love the mode and i'm it sucks that i
can't
live in the mode the way i would live in
pve and they still have a long ways to
go
you know and um you know we know
crossplay is going to help somewhat but
we got to be careful obviously with pc
pc guys coming in there wrecking uh uh
you know the console guys so there has
to be an optional thing which they i
think
they kind of alluded to but um
it the disparity is too much you know
it's too much and we get it
it's destiny a lot of it is gonna always
lean pve
but there's times when i do my pinnacles
i wanna live in that mode and i feel
it's just this it's not rewarding enough
there's not enough commitment we already
talked about
armor we already talked about different
titles like
you know outside of the flawless and you
know it's really two to it's two versus
a zillion title or pve titles right
right so
yeah it's just man they really really
gotta do a better job
and again i'm gonna be realistic with a
season i don't know but
it's gotta happen at some point you know
because you're good you're just
ostracizing a huge part of the community
that really loves that game mode and we
just need it man so
yeah i feel that i feel that
i mean bungie made halo we can't forget
about that
i i promise you if if you've played halo
you can close your eyes and you can see
seven at least seven halo maps in your
head
through you could you could guide me
through them with a blindfold on
and i would be able to walk the halls
you know the halo map yeah it's like
where are the maps man you know we're
the map it's it's a travesty we have no
beyond light crucible map nothing and
then how
did we get with shadow keep like how
many maps came with shadow key
i mean original maps came with shadows
original maps
no other maps though no other no other
moon maps and we have no europa maps
no right that's like we still got trials
is still taking place on mercury
this weekend yeah mercury's not even
there
yeah that's yeah no it's that's
that's kind of one of those things it's
like what do people do on the weekends
if they
want to push pvp so much and trials is
like their big weekend activity whether
it's broken or not
when the loot is there those numbers
tend to go up but in the middle of the
week when trials isn't there man what is
there to do it's like so
believe me i 100 agree it's like no new
maps not a whole lot of stuff going on
the loot i mean i mean whether it was
ascendant nomad doing his thing
so many people have said like just the
just everything from it
whether it be the loot of what you get
like the exclusives you go for
the just the modes the modes
we haven't had and then you have like
what a showdown comes up and i saw some
i was watching somebody and i was like
well i don't even remember what showdown
because nobody cares
yeah it's like what are these weird
crappy modes that manage to stay around
but we can't get a new one like this is
this is weird so no mine would be
uh my first one's gonna be for the new
lights
keep keep that experience like that
still needs to work because if we got
another three years and you continue to
want to bring new people into this
to experience the story we need to find
some way to
have this stuff happen if kaido remains
an ally and we go into which queen and
they can't see a cinematic that happens
the story beats the wind on and get a
little bit of a preview of like what
happened there like
the storyboard cinematic what's going on
with crow if the helm leaves or moves
what all of that stuff but also on the
other side you see things like banshee
and his mods like
there are mods that make their random
cycle through like twice a year
and these people are trying and just
yeah make them all buyable
at some point make them all available
that type of stuff for
somebody who hasn't been in the game for
a while zurich is kind of there for the
exotics and those will
kind of get accumulated he's a mess but
like that's all
that might be my other one when we get
around there but he's a mess anyway
but like the whole the new player
experience like now again like
you play forsaken you can't go
experience the red war they have no
attachment to cave but he dies in the
first mission of forsaken spoiler alert
sorry
too late um all that type of stuff as
you go through you're like
how does somebody jump into this game if
they haven't been in it already
at all like if they didn't play destiny
one and then came back
seriously they do have no clue who came
out was what's going on yeah
yeah i was like and then you go into
those and you get a long goodbye from
the inside terminus that's like sunset
and i'm like why is that even happening
right so just those though the new
the new person gets to enjoy their
experience that's
i know it's a big ask it's not a small
one but like shahan
this is a baby step baby baby baby's
dead
at the bare minimum anything that's
vaulted like the red war
should have almost like a storyboard yep
for the new light okay this is what
happened right right this dominance golf
figure coming you do a little you don't
even have to
put a lot of big budget they've done it
before with the the zavala
assassination attempt right you know
they showed it in a storyboard fashion
show just let cause again i'm running
again i gotta use reign as an example
yes
if i i'm literally doing story time
around all right ransom this is why this
guy's here and this is what happened
here
why because he will have no context to
what's going on and to why so
yeah absolutely absolutely that has to
new light and and
chronological order give people the
steps
on which to attempt the kind of he's
like yo should i be doing shadow keep
now should i be doing this now
there's just they're just vomiting quest
icons on the map and stuff and no one
has no context
that you can't assume the player base is
all hardcore
yeah no i mean that's that's so great i
mean i
as a sherpa i mean like i'm i'm sure
about throwing through that's like
pretty much all i do is like
that but it's like that's if there's
anything i'm ever known for it will be
that
and i still like whenever i have like
friends that reach out to me from
outside of the destiny universe
uh the very few that exist um
and they're like how do i get into
destiny i can't tell them
and all i do is teach people how to play
this game and that's
i can't even explain like how to get
into it properly
yeah it's it's impossible like it's not
it's not impossible like i could be like
oh it's a great game but it's like
how much can you hype up a game in the
characters in the story and the lore of
something
that just doesn't have value to people
from the outside that haven't been
playing since d1 you know good point
yep good point that's like it's just
that's the thing man like i just can't
i just can't jump in behind it it's a
valid point brother i don't know
a point good wouldn't you yeah all right
so second one for you and then we'll
wrap this thing up
second one uh is easily like rework the
class system
uh you know even even from not playing
out writers and seeing the stuff without
writers
and from the other mmos like i've played
over the years like class system's huge
stasis the way the stasis is done love
it or hate it is flawless it is amazing
i don't really like how much like how to
unlock stuff uh yeah they're not a big
family
that's a little little wrong yeah i have
not i
again i play this game so much i can't
even tell you
i don't have the latest one the one
that's come with the season i don't have
like the latest thing i don't either i
don't know i'm finished i'm
with you i don't know i don't even know
but i don't even know what the hunter
one does i don't like tori
yeah the warlock grenade turret like the
boom like that i fixed it
and then the the titan one like throws
up the ice wall that's cool
i don't know what the hunter one does i
don't i'm like looking at for someone to
say it in chat so i can be like oh yeah
that's it
it's like i'm a hunter
but like seeing void uh hunter
because that's always gonna be my baby
seeing that go back to like a d1 kind of
element
or like even take on like the new breath
that uh
they're seeing right now like i just
wanna see that and
more classes come in you know like a lot
of people have been speculating that
like
are we gonna get more darkness classes
like i think we will like yeah i think
it'll be cool to have like a
um this is something that we were
talking about during the present you
know like all like the the darkness
vines and stuff like that
like maybe we're going to see like an
overgrowth like darkness class or
maybe we'll see like a siva class or
something like that like there could be
like some cool things that they do there
but the class system just needs reworked
because like you know if you come from
another mmo
um and you have all you have specific
roles you have the dps role
right now in destiny i feel like we're
all just dps
there's no um yeah there's no healer
built like
you can have a well of radiance you can
have like a healing grenade but it's
like that's it
yeah that's it like where's my tank why
can't my titans pull aggro off of
enemies
why am i running around invisible and
still getting shot at
by things seriously instead of like the
the the big old titan
you know rocketing at my enemy he's
shooting at him
but he's still trying to find me and i'm
invisible running around it's like no
like focus on the big guy
like come on um so like i just think
like the class system
needs to have a stronger emphasis on
play style and like also be reworked
to allow more custom customization
that's my thing that's a huge ask i see
that's not happening that's not
happening by february
no i was like but they did stasis like
are they gonna introduce the next
subclass which everybody assumes they
said
this is the first hints first darkness
subclass
are is the next system gonna look like
that one and the old one still or that
is like are they always gonna remain
different like that it's like no i'm
with you yeah it's like i have the
you have 20 points and outrageous just
go into a skill tree and you can barely
get to the end of one of them
like you really specialize in a
playstyle and now you're just like one
two three
like it just does not have the same feel
of like
really going deep into a build how do i
want to play do i want to go ultra tank
or do i want to go stupid dps like
there is no glass cannon in this game
that doesn't exist in every other rpg
there's always one right so you don't
get to play that but that being said
cognito i know you're up but people are
throwing some stuff at me here yeah
you you got work to do sir the chat was
some fitness out of e
so yeah man like for me it's been um i
think
and he would appreciate this is arbor
right like the commitment
to it in a sense oh it's time it's time
ladies and gentlemen
it's the squad who put the squats in the
chat who redeemed who who's the evil
person out here
here we go you know what it is what's
your clan name it's called ashton
exactly this is what this is it's aston
grass right here he's a legit
squatch with proper formula look it's
the last word man it's
a pandemic you can't get to the gym you
gotta you gotta cover the last word you
gotta get you get your squats in you
gotta get your good form
you're the chat it's the last
flawless man this is what you get here
this is what you're getting i don't know
who oh it's back from the dead you're an
evil man you got e out here doing scars
but look what what
can't what's the um actual supplement
that he could use unleash that
while after after this amazing physical
activity is there a supplement that he
could possibly utilize
i i you know i think he should go take a
sip of that focus he's using over there
[Laughter]
you guys are full of crap
let's go we got it in it's been a while
it's been a while good form sir
you need a good supplement to to finish
that uh show you this activity yeah
yeah what you got in recovery
right here yeah oh oh there it is
you got that one yep yep oh let's go
hold up let's go let's go
oh no i got too many best best flavor
which one is the best flavor
i try to not touch this area as much as
possible the rest of it no one else no
one can see
but this area give me top three flavors
we gotta we gotta do one more final top
two oh man top three flavors of focus
yep oh that's that's that's super easy
all right so
the good game bro strawberry lemonade uh
first of all good game bro is a
fantastic creator he is an amazing human
being if you guys like sports and like
call of duty and stuff like that
yeah i got a fun okay he has he has a
really good podcast from rare drop
he does sport talks and uh he does
modern warfare uh
uh warzone stuff like that fantastic
creator
his flavor amazing absolute flawless
flavor
love the strawberry lemonade um didn't
think i would like it i'm not really a
strawberry lemonade guy
um but i love it i've went through like
two jars already
nice um i frost bolts uh
flavor frostberry second one that one
if you he did an interview with somebody
and in that interview he was like i want
the flavor to just be
drinkable i wanted it to be something
drinkable
but like like you want to drink it not
for the focus element of it but the fact
that like
you just want to drink it you know like
you get those hunches with a drink
sometimes it's like i just want to taste
it you know
uh and that's it like frostbolt's flavor
is amazing
uh and then the cherry limeade it's like
one that's like always hits home
can't go wrong like some people it's
like a 50 50. it's like a flip of a coin
some people are like really into it some
people aren't
honorable mention is the g1 gummy yeah
oh man that's a flavor um but like
there's those three flavors i could just
live off of those are those around
nice yeah so for me lately strawberry
lemonade
i kept saying it on twitter too i was
like you guys do a lemonade i'm gonna
make eat
too much already so i remember that i
remember that
so yeah strawberry lemonade is a must i
literally like as soon as it went live
about three of them was just like nope
done
so bought too many of those birthday
cake and chocolate milk is like freaking
dessert
that is just amazing i might have to
um i have not tried that but now you
wanna
like my advice um
shake it up but then put it back in the
fridge let the foam kind of settle back
down because shake milk kind of get a
little foamy
so let it settle back down oh like
that's dessert right there it's
absolutely amazing you don't
oh so good um
number three cherry limeade's got to be
in there too like cherry limeade for me
was like the first like
fruit steering limeade was my first
purchase because it was like i love
cherry limeade and then i was like
and it nailed it now i will tell you
take cherry limeade
and frostberry put them together uh-oh
so yeah that sounds pretty solid and
then honorable mention for me dream team
punch also pretty standard pretty solid
ah yeah i can't forget about this it's
energy one so i don't really go for it
too often
i'm all about the focus ones um i like
the energy ones don't get me wrong
but dream team punch is definitely like
the best like it is definitely
that's when you say drinkable i'm like
frostburg is a good tube it's like dream
team punch i'm just like
just like two too many like
i gotta make sure that's up till like
four years elixir
that's my workout drink is a is a dream
punch that's like that's like my
um i don't like um what's that
pre-workout i don't like those like they
make me
interested in too much yeah yeah dude so
like my pre-workout dream team punch
nice i gotta get man i gotta try this
stuff man i've been procrastinating
i've been touching i was like
the unofficially sponsored podcast at
least we'll just drink it so
what did it for me and what got me into
it because before i started doing stuff
with them
i was a was a fan of the product um for
a little bit
um because i i drank the bad one before
you know the the
one that starts with a g you know it's a
four letter word i did that but i did
that to come off of my
like red bull addiction i had i had like
a really bad like coconut red bull
addiction i would drink like four of
them a day
all the time not good for you man no no
no and and i found out these like gaming
supplements you know
have um like that were healthier for you
and so that led me all the way to
advanced and that's
that's been what that's what did it man
get away from me yes celebrity bro
that's that red bull monster man yeah
yeah that's those are those are bad like
the nice thing is like you look at the
label it's like what's in there it's
like you can literally tell
like the open because i looked around
too it's like i tried
most of them i didn't try the one we we
don't speak of the voldemort
we don't speak of the voldemort one but
it's like i tried all the others just
and but i was like
something about the tastes like they're
all just if you have an idea like how it
might taste in your head
right and you may not like cotton candy
i was like i don't know what the hell
that's gonna taste like it's weirdly
good
like that one for me so i was like if
you want something like you know instead
of your cup of coffee just give it a
shot honestly like
try them out there they're excellent and
i've used them for pre-work i work at
sometimes i get up at 4 30 in the
morning because i teach kickboxing
classes and that's
literally like it's fitness kickboxing
i'm not muay thai so don't fight me
because i'll probably lose
hey did you know i didn't multitask muay
thai is that why you brought that up
no seriously you did i didn't know that
yeah yeah oh no you'd kick my ass in a
fight that's that's fine
honestly where i'm at in life now i'd
much prefer fitness kickboxing i'm
trying to like get way back into shape
see exactly much prefer that yeah so
it's like
it's that but i was like if you got a 5
30 class i'm like literally what i do
because it's usually two classes in the
morning
that's what that's what that's my
morning not pre-workout not anything
else i will tell you i start my day
like every workday with that that's
literally what i do because it's the
right balance for teaching it doesn't
have to be like
pre-workout crazy tingles or anything
like that i'm like i just need to like
i want to be up and awake and kick butt
in my classes and it's like and it's the
right level for me but i've also like
gone to tate class and same thing so i
was like i've
i've done the same thing and it's been i
really there's always a couple flavors
i would love to pick the brain of like
logistics and then like you know peter
and then like fargo and a couple of
those guys to understand like the flavor
testing and stuff because it's like
because it was the strawberry lemonade
and for me and i was like i tasted i was
like i want a little bit more lemon
and i sent a message to him and he's
like some people love the flavor and i
was like and
some people absolutely did my wife
actually liked it and she doesn't like
most of the flavors so you see actually
what's the one for me before the gyms
well i don't know what's the one
i'm supposed to be taking before the gym
so if i try this stuff that y'all
out here cool you could probably do
either but the energy is just gonna be
your
kind of more like normal pre-workout the
focus will be more the mental
cognitive as well so like you're like in
a workday like i gotta knock this out i
got a lot of stuff to do like work focus
like
in front of it that's your focus but the
energy like dream team punch like you
want that to go
that's probably your one to try for a
pre-workout just like light boost
always that's what i tell people like
energy is like the light boost it's like
you know you're it's meant to be
sippable you drink it and then
yeah like uh like advances was saying
it's like the focus like that's where
it's at like that's where like the
mental stuff kind of comes into play
like
the stuff with your eyes and the science
behind that like
i'm just a cog in the wheel like there's
all the studies on the website we'll
explain it farther but
um a bonsai's honestly like my fiance
she's the same way like miss
like she loves strawberry lemonade the
g1 gummy like those are her flavors
and i mean she's like she is like a real
life superhero like she's a um
she's a social worker so like she has
like yeah that's something
jobs you know um and so like i i can't
keep up with what she does and like so
if she's having like one of those days
where it's like meetings back to back to
back to back to back to back to back
like focus is what she's like she's
gonna grab that like strawberry and
lemonade like
you know she's like hey you know
whenever you're making one can you grab
me one two i'm like yeah nice
right so that's where it kind of comes
into play absolutely
yeah i gotta try it man gotta try it
mm-hmm uh i don't know what i missed
while i did my squats and we got on the
advanced tangent but that was fine
yeah i just stole your point i just said
armor their true commitment
legendary stuff yeah that's that kind of
stuff too i was like yeah that's
probably my second one too is armor 3.0
it's been my biggest one that will
continue to be is whatever armor 3.0 is
going to be
is it's witch queen whatever they
mentioned like
uh joe blackburn in his previous article
before the big state of the game he's
like we don't want armor to be this like
yearly stat rotation i'm like
please tell me what that's going to be
because i played too many other games
where it matters
where stats matter where like i can't
run faster when i have mobility still
blows my mind like that type of thing is
just kind of bonkers to me so
i mix that's why i was like witch queen
for me is just i'm hoping it blows me
away
i know it's like a high bar to shoot for
but the story right now with armor
switches those alone
if they can keep this going that's why
i'm like you delayed as long as you want
to deliver what you need to
that's my hope yeah i know i'm all about
that for sure
so that is about all we got chat you
guys have been amazing thank you guys
very much tonight it's been an awesome
time um
but sir sutlich man thank you very much
for coming on it has been an absolute
blast getting to know you
um thank you very much but at this point
kind of the floor is yours i mean we
talked a little bit about your
sharpening but
where can they find you what can they do
like what's the raffle system you got
going like
explain explain your world because the
floor is yours right now for anybody
listening
yeah yeah so i'll grab the floor real
fast
so so yeah uh sherpa non-stop sherpa
first
um i tried my first thing you know i am
a destiny writer so like i do got
to deliver the news uh best i can so i
always uh where do you write sir
oh i do uh write for destiny tracker you
guys can go to destinytracker.com i mean
everyone goes to destiny tracker already
you're looking for destiny matters
look if you haven't
a lot of the articles all the guides and
stuff like that so
um always writing up there and so like
that's kind of like where the core of
the content is like doing that stuff
so that way we can make the stuff to
teach and show other people nice and
then after that
we spend the rest of the time showing
other people you know and
you know walking people through it as
much as we can to get people through
there
um what else do we do chat
a lot right now they're all lives like
uh we do pokemon of course you know
that's the new thing that we've been
doing so
um pokemon uh we do it saturday mornings
now
it's like uh our modern take on um
saturday morning cartoons you know
so uh i do nuzlocke runs where chat gets
to keep a pokemon
uh everyone in chat just gives out i
catch something we do the nuzlocke run
where you can only catch
one pokemon in each area chat names it
um and then whoever named it whoever
name i pick
that's their pokemon and if it makes all
the way to the end is in the final team
they get vip or merch uh at the end of
uh
you know at the end of it um but other
than that yeah just
trying to make sure we get as many
people through those activities as
possible in destiny
um i think that's it i'm pretty sure
that's all i do
i like to play i write and i entertain
all right yeah okay cool yeah yeah i
think i i think i did it right right
i'm looking at this uh yeah there's a
destiny tracker.com article man this is
how to get the
the grandma complete the game master
arms healer okay get the [ __ ]
very detailed oh okay it's not as
detailed as i'd like it to be as soon as
i got done with it i was like man
there are some things that i missed in
there uh that i need i definitely need
to add in there but it's like man
not brothers well coming from someone
who's long-winded i appreciate the
detail
so yeah literally any video i do i'm
like this probably should be half the
length but this is just my style so
i like being i can't do videos i i'm so
bad at editing videos i
like an article will take me like in a
couple hours to write
yeah but if i tried to make that article
that is like literally the scripts if i
try to make that into a video
it'll be done in eight like 18 days
probably i can't do it
you're like three weeks ago yeah that's
what they was like well there's no point
in doing it now so
you know there goes all that file you
know all that's really good man
i love i love how you even have the uh
weapon selections and stuff like that
and why
good stuff good stuff right yeah doing
it doing it up
yeah i'm trying to yeah but that is it
you can find me
uh on twitch subledge uh twitter
instagram stuff i'm super lucky with my
name uh that like i got
everything no no underscores nothing
crazy um
i was given my my gamertag name and i've
just stuck with it it's off of my last
name but
yeah yeah i was like i got the last name
so what's the ledge for
cuz i know what i know what the first
part of the name is coming from it's
like your name but what's the ledge
right yes so i had uh i will sure
you don't jump off the ledge yeah right
exactly
yeah um i i'm constantly falling off of
ledges um
no the uh my so i had a 10th grade
english teacher
um she was like my best friend and like
i love writing like um
which is why right now and uh she always
whenever she would call on me she would
always call me sutledge so she'd be like
subledge like you know like i would
raise my hand i'd be like yes teacher
i'd like to answer this question
and she'll be like sutlej what's up and
then that would and so like
i named that was my xbox name and then
it became my
twitch name after a while so yeah yeah
mine's weird as well but nice to have
unique names you don't have to fight
anybody for it be like yep that's just
me everywhere so
that's the perk of it right that's you
exactly you don't have to fight anyone
if i can't get subledged on the platform
it means that i already made an account
and forgot the password
that's what's happening probably true
yeah yeah that's that's
that's what's happening well if
anybody's listening from last week it
sounds like his teacher was giving him
top
top stamps all the time so okay top
stamp yes
[Laughter]
uh cognito what do you got coming up i
know you've had some awesome guests
coming through ilp so what's on the
docket for you
yeah wait before i get into that yeah i
guess i'll let you pull it out man
great great love layer to your story the
unique gaming all that good stuff
the multi-faceted and talented
subtleties i should say
stand-up comedian detective you know you
have like all these different stars
figured out in the end you were italian
yeah like his resume is ill like
i'm just looking at the bullet points in
my mind yeah yeah
trying to try something he's like what
do you want to do for a lot
that's literally what it was too it was
like i just i don't know it's so so many
things to choose from
nice and it's varied pokemon halo i love
it love most of them
but yeah man you know for me again a lot
of talking about twitter all that good
stuff yes
shout out to edex you know iop has been
definitely been getting some love lately
so appreciate the support
this week we will have mc fixer he will
be from
the uk so uh gonna talk to him he's
probably kind of like the kind of funny
communities
as well as um probably like microsoft as
well different things so he
runs a cool podcast so we'll talk gaming
sunday 1pm eastern on ironworldpodcast
youtube
and again salute to launchgaming.net man
really appreciate the support we've got
some cool articles out there check it
out
we're looking for dusty writers we're
looking for dusty writers
but all jokes if you got your
commitments but um nah all seriously i
really appreciate it you know when we
had the uh jason ronald interview
and stuff like that we put that up on
the uh as far as the series x creator
and stuff like that it's been really
cool to see and of course you know we
got that last word podcast on uh
every friday you know that underrated
thing that most don't know about but
have a lot of fun sometimes
absolutely with the great co-host at a
squat master himself today other days
and something else but
you guys don't know it was actually leg
day like four hours ago
so thank you for the squats appreciate
that
we just got done doing weighted lunges
and i did like 60 barbell
dead or dumbbell deadlifts we don't have
a barbell at home but it was homework
out but yeah legs are hurting
so yeah if i'm walking funny tomorrow
thank you guys for the bonus
i appreciate that um but again to wrap
up slutledge thank you for coming in man
it was a blast getting to know you
talking and thank you for all that you
do in the community for the sherpas and
just honestly trying to find
positivity in the world of lfg and give
people that hope of like
there are some good strangers out there
in the destiny community and there's
more than people think
but some bad experiences really turned
people off so i'm glad that you're one
of the
the lights out there being like hey
we're the lighthouse get over here we'll
get you through them so
i may not get you to the lighthouse but
we're gonna get you to the the grand
master chest that's that's
the grand bastard yeah yeah
seriously it's been an absolute pleasure
being on and talking with you guys it's
like
well it was so much fun well thank you
we appreciate that
um but for everybody in chat for
everybody you guys know where to find me
it's a bond to several minds always easy
perk of again having a unique name uh
but for episode 142
the number keeps climbing thank you guys
very much march 26 episode 142 thank you
guys very much and for this episode
it has been the last word